django is a high-level python web
framework that enables rapid development
of secure and maintainable websites in
this five-hour course you will learn
django by building a simple social media
application
this is a great course for people new to
django and for people who are familiar
with django and want to learn how to
build a social media application
tommy taco teaches this course he has
created many popular courses on the
freecodecamp channel and his own channel
i encourage you to leave a comment with
the most interesting thing you learn
from for the benefit of other campers
who are watching this course hi guys
welcome to this video and i want to say
thank you to free code cam for
publishing this course and you're going
to check out more tutorials like this
you can check out my channel at kobitomi
and for more of my content you can also
follow me on twitter i'm going to leave
a link in the description below
so now let me show you around
everything we're going to be building in
this project
so this is the end product of this
project
so as you can see we have a feed so this
is just a post feed where we see the
post of the users that we are following
and then once we have this we also
implemented a fixture which can allow us
to like a user support and just click on
the button and now you see it says like
by one person so now we can also click
on the button again and no likes so we
can like and unlike a post
we can also click on the name on that
post and then it takes us to the profile
page of that post
so now in this profile page we can see
the profile image username the bio the
amount of posts these users have the
followers and the following
so now if we unfollow this user we see
now that this is our zero follower let's
follow him back just to support him now
we asked one follower so we added these
followers and following feature because
also social media without the followers
and following feature
and now after that
right here we can just see a list of all
the posts the users have and we can
click on it
and once we click on one we'll be able
to scroll through all the images of all
the posts the user have easily
now we can come back to the um
and as you can see we right here we have
this users you can follow
so we did a little bit of suggestion
field here
the currently logged in user will make
sure that the users that has been
suggested and not people that is
following already that's so right now if
we click on view user you see that we
are not following this user that's why
it has been suggested
and this is a brand new user he has no
post no follower no
if we follow this user right now
he has one follower and we go back to
the home you see that that user is not
suggested again now that's because we
already followed our user so we can be
suggesting someone that you already
follow
now after that we also added a picture
which will allow us to upload pictures
so we can just choose the picture write
the caption hit upload and then
the people that are following us will be
able to see our new our latest book
and we also have this
account settings feature for that the
first thing we did in this project was
to
do the user authentication where a user
can sign into our platform and register
on our platform which is very important
and also when it's logged in you can log
out
if i log out right now
you'll see
that we have this login so i can just
log in since it's already autofilled
and now we have that
and we come here and we can click on
account settings and right here we can
change our profile image of bio our
location and everything we need to
change
press cancel just takes us back
and we also have this search function
which is also key so we know we have a
user that is named jasper so let's come
here and just say jazz
and let's set you see that it gives us
jasper uses his location la and his bio
if we click on just bar we can see his
page this is also a brand new user so
this is basically what we're going to be
building
and note that you can add a lot of
pictures that you want to add yourself
also because after this project the main
purpose of this project is to introduce
you to things you can do with jungle so
i hope that after this course you will
be
comfortable with django and you can take
what you learned from this course into
your own project to build your own
project or even enhance this at our
point having all this said i also want
to say that the source code to this
project
here you can get the template file so as
you can see we're using a template for
this project where you can get the
template file we use and the old source
code to everything we coded
i'm going to have a github link to the
source code
and you can just easily get the template
file and full and code along
and
you can just get your source code also
so if you are stuck somewhere and just
easily check that out
so for the beginners taking this
tutorial i'm just going to quickly give
a brief introduction to chango
so what exactly is django
django is a python web framework and
what i mean by that is that using django
you can build web applications with the
python programming language
now if you recently learnt python or you
know python already and you are looking
to go into the web development view and
django is a good choice for you
now there are various reasons why
companies and developers choose to use
django
some of these reasons are because django
is fast there's a large community
jungle provides security to your
application django is also very scalable
and these are just few of the reasons
why developers choose to use django but
one key one is that django has a very
large community now this is important so
that when you encounter an error when
you're stuck on something you can easily
search that error and there's
probability that someone has already
solved it for you online maybe on stack
overflow or something now this is very
important so that
you can easily fix your bugs or fix your
errors by just a google search so django
has that large community of a lot of
developers around it
so having this said
i hope you have an understanding of what
django is and why you should even choose
django let's go to the next section
now the first thing we want to do
is to create a new django project
so i'm in this folder here which is just
i created a new folder named socialbook
the social book is gonna be the name of
the
social media application that we are
building
i just created a new folder on
on my computer in documents that doesn't
really matter but what i just need is to
get this
directory to that folder so this is
where i want to create my django project
and
develop everything
so now that i have the directory to that
folder i'm just going to open up my
command prompt
right here
so you might be on a mac you might just
open up your terminal or any other osu i
just open up the terminal in there
so right here i'm just going to go into
that particular directory so right now
i'm in that directory if i press dir you
see it's empty
let me press cls to close it up
i'm going to be building this
social media application from scratch to
the finish so i'm going to show you how
i build
applications
when i'm developing my site project or
something so you can totally relate with
it
so right now we are in this directory
and
if you are new to django
when we want to create a jungle project
we use some command lines so to create a
new jungle project what we will do is to
say jungle
i think admin
start project
and then the name of the project right
here so this will be the name of the
project so this is the command line we
use to create a new tango project
but before you even want to create a
jungle project you need to make sure
that you have django installed
now you know in python we have pip which
is a python package manager if you
install python we have python installed
already it should come with it
just to make sure we have django
installed we're going to
keep
install
tango
so this is going to install the latest
version of django for us
now i already have this installed on my
computer on my laptop
so it should tell me that requirements
already satisfied now that's because i
already have it installed but for you if
you don't have it installed if you're
new to django as i said it should go
ahead and install that for you so it's
going to pop up now and tell me
requirement already
so we should do that
second
okay we can just
out of that
and
so i canceled the operation because i
already have that
so i'm just closed i like cleaning up
the command
so right now let's just create a new
django project in this particular folder
so what i did i first came into the
folder make sure i have django installed
and now it's time to create a new jungle
project
i'll say django
in admin
that project
i'm going to name it social
book
so this is going to create a new folder
named social book this particular
directory now if i press d ir you see
now that i have a new directory a folder
named socialbook i also go back to that
folder now i have a new folder name so
i go into it you're gonna see that it
creates this
other folder name socialbook and the
file name manage.p
so
just gonna go into that particular
jungle project i just created by saying
cd social book
now i should have money dot py and
social brokerage
i come back here and enter the social
book again i'm gonna see some files
which is basically just the files that
django create get application
so now that we have this django app
running we can just test it out by
running it on our server but what we're
going to do first is to create
our django app so we have a jungle
project and we have a jungle app to take
all the functionality
so let me just quickly explain the
difference between a jungle project and
an app so take facebook.com for example
we have facebook.com which is the main
project so for here we have socialbook
which is the main project but let's say
you want to have a picture like messages
or notifications or post feed each of
those can be different apps no now it
depends on how you want to do it me
personally i like having one project and
one app and that app can take all the
functionalities like all the pictures
the logging in signing of authentication
and everything
but
normally you can have a project and
different functionalities as the app so
let's say facebook.com as i said is the
main project facebook is a project here
then
we can have like the authentication
scheme as
a different app just to take care of the
authentication and what i mean by that
is user authentication means logging in
and registering a user
we can also have another app to take
care of the notifications we can have
another app for the messaging platform
so that is just
the basic understanding of difference
between django app and jungle project so
you can see a django app is like a
subset of django project but for this
project we're just going to have one app
that's going to take care of everything
so now that we're in here let's just
create a new django app
and the command is similar to creating a
django project so we'll do django
iphone admin
that app
and we'll name the app
because it's taking care of everything
and we're not giving it a specific name
and just say call
but i like maybe my app score just
that's just me or you can name it
anything you want totally
now if i press dir i have a new folder
named core i come back in now i have a
new folder name call and in there i have
this bunch of files
that we're going to be looking into
later when we are using them to develop
so right now i have everything taken
care of i've created my jungle widget
and i've added an app to it
now let me just run this project and
make sure that everything is working
fine on the server
so to run your project or even see if
the installation has worked successfully
all you need to do is to say python
manage dot py
run server
now note that if you're on a mac you
need to add python three money dot pyro
server because the recent version of
django doesn't support python 2.
so as you can see it gives us this
output just ignore this for now and what
you just want us to do is to go to this
url
on our browser
right here we can paste it
and then it should
boom so this is it what this is now is
that it's saying that we have
successfully created our django project
and is working successfully
and see here
is the install work successfully
congratulations now this simply means
that everything we created has worked
successfully so
this is the url that we're going to be
seeing all our project or the output of
our project in
so that's the local oh sport 8000 that's
the default url for django when you run
your jungle on your local server on your
machine
it is
now that we've created our jungle
project and stuff
this is basically the home url of our
website but when a user comes to our
website like socialbook.com we don't
want this to show right we want to show
like our own template our own design you
know our on social media so let's get
into that
let's go ahead and set up our urls
we're gonna go into visual studio code
now
if i come here i have my visual studio
code open and i have imported the
project we just created let me quickly
walk you through how to do that so
just make sure you have visual studio
code or any other you know code editor
that you're using
and on right here
click on open folder and once you click
on noble folder just go to the folder
where we created
this django project and it's going to
open up that project for you right here
like
this so what we just want to do
as you can see right here we have core
which is the app we created and we have
sociable which is the
main project we created but we don't
have money dot py and some other files
if i come back to my folder right here
see that we should have money dot py and
sqlite database but it's not there that
means they didn't import why
i was selecting so what we just need to
do is to come to file open
folder and make sure you don't select
anything just open the old folder and
you should
so we don't want to save anything yet
because this is seeing it as a workspace
we just want to open it as before
now you should go ahead and open that
folder up for us and then once we have
this opened
what we just need to do is to set up our
urls
and so this answer is
as you can see now we have everything
imported or opened but now let's go
ahead and set up our urls
so if you don't understand what i mean
by urls what i just simply mean is the
path
of our website so when a user comes to
socialbook.com should it go or what
should happen or when a user comes to
socialbook.com profile what should
happen so basically each of those paths
are urls like socialbook.com
profile is a url that we need to set up
once the user comes to slash profile
something will happen but we don't set
that url up then it doesn't exist don't
worry you're gonna get this
the first thing we want to do
to come into our app
and create a new file in there and name
it urls.py
so right here now we're just going to
import something from django
if from
angle.urls
import path
now this part is going to allow us to be
able to set up our urls and now we're
going to have a new list and name it url
buttons
and now to set up our home url a path
and we leave it blank once we leave it
blank like this this is signifying that
we're setting up our own url where we do
something like
profile
this is signifying our setting up our
website slash profile
so now
after this we put a comma
and we'll say
use dot
index
and we'll give it a name of index
so what this is doing is that this views
is where basically
do most of our coding so
you are going to understand what i mean
by view dot index in a bit but first of
all before we can even access these
views so these views right here that
we're saying is this view.py file in the
same directory i'm just going to go
ahead and open that
so before we can access that file we
need to import it
so we'll save from
dot
import
use
now we have views imported we can use
views.index
but if risingviews.index is no function
or no class or anything like index in
here so we need to set that up also i'm
just giving it a name like a keyword for
this particular url
index
so basically what is the same is that
once the user comes to the home url
go to the views.index whatever is being
done there
just basically show that to the user so
now we can save this
i'm going to come into views now we need
to set up a new function for the index
i need to take a request
now we can return a simple http response
but first we need to import that
from
django.http
import
http
response
now we can just say
return an http response
h1
and
say welcome
to
social book
now this is what we need to say so let
me explain what i did here so as i said
right here what we did was imported
parts imported views and then we set up
a new url named
the home url which is empty and we said
it should go to the views.index and this
view.index basically is coming to this
views file i need to go to dot index
look for any function that is not index
so now that it has dot index whatever is
being done here in this function is what
is going to serve that particular url
so now since we're just sending an http
response this is just what it's going to
show
let me save it now
one more thing
before we can
this can reflect on our main project we
need to set the urls up on our main
project as you can see we set it up on
our app but if we come into social book
coming to urls here what we just need to
do
is to import something called include
and now we just have to set up the home
url that's the only thing we need to set
up right here
and we'll say if someone comes to the
home url
just include
or
dot urls
what this is saying is that if someone
comes into the home url in code
cloud.urls now this call to arrays is
our app which is for dot urls which is
so it's going to go into code urls and
look for any path that is similar to
this and whatever is being done there is
what
which is this path
and then this part also links to
views.index which is right here so
everything just link back to returning
this http response now this is done
let's just make sure our server is
running
so this gave us an error when we use
views.index but we haven't defined index
in the views wire file let's go ahead
and refresh this
right and refresh this now
it should update
and not give us any error because
obviously we've already added that index
function in our views
so it still says index is not defined so
let's make sure we saved our views of
people
right here
also
it's reloading
let's see
okay
let's make sure everything is working
fine too this one is first of all
okay so
you have
or the two arrows in line five you say
index
in here first of all
save that so it can reload so sometimes
we need to like reload and let's just do
use
dot
index
name
x
save again
now let's see once it reloads
dude as you can see now everything is
working so sometimes
jungle just need a little bit of
tweaking or reloading so it can update
now let's go back to
this that we run and we shouldn't see
this again now
what we should see now is that http
response welcome to social books as you
can see what we see now is welcome to
subscriber so basically we've removed
that default jungle template i was
showing in stores work and we've given
this http response on our own url but
this is still not what we want what we
want is to show a template basically
that's what we're gonna do
now let's go ahead and set up our
template
so if i come in here into the folder
it's going to go right here
right here and you see i have one folder
called template here so this is just
basically the template for that we're
going to use in this tutorial so it's
just a free template
and everything the whole template and
everything will be
in the github link of this project so
you can get the template also
and i have these two templates here one
is for the profile one is what is for
the main
for the index sign up everything
and what i just want to do is to
drag this
i'll select it first of all and i'm
going to drag the html files into a
particular folder but before that let's
come into our visual studio code
so before we can
even use any template we need to do some
configurations writing vs code
let's close this social book where else
we don't need that again
now we want to go into our settings.py
file
and right underneath here we just want
to import os first of all and
let's scroll down
so in installed apps when you first
create an app it's always advisable to
add the app in here now this is not
relating to the template but just so we
don't get an error later let's add that
up
so now that we have that
let's scroll down
right here where you see this template
is a list
and what you're just going to do is to
come into dares and this desk is just
specifying the
where jungle should go and look for all
our template files so let's just
stop and in the
base directory of this project now when
i say base directory i mean the same
directory which contains the money.py
file
so the base directory of this project
we're going to create a new file and
we'll name it templates
and in here is where all the html files
of this project is going to be so we
need to tell django that that is where
everything is going to be that's what
we're going to do right here so first of
all we need to import os as we d we're
going to come right here under this i'm
going to say
os the path
the join
page there which is the base directory
go into template
so it says from the base they're going
to template that's where you should look
for all our templates files it that's
basically all we need in telling jungle
where to look for our templates files so
we just save that and right here in our
template files now we need to load it up
with our html files let's come
back here
and we'll drag that
just copy it in there good so now we
have that in there we need to copy one
more
which is
from the profile
so go to static dom profile
now i will explain what i mean by this
static dom profile later
let's just take this profile
so again all this is going to be
available in the github link of this
tutorial so you can easily grab them
and yeah so right now we have all the
html files of this template now
and what we can just do now if i close
this up
don't need this for now
we can go into the views file
and instead of returning an http
response we can now render an html page
so this is the index function obviously
we want to render the index.html
what we do say return
render
take a request
get index.html
so this is just the line of code we need
to show this index.html file
now
let's make sure everything is running
good and let's come back here and hit
refresh i should see this again and we
should see that template
let's give it a moment to
load that up okay good as you can see
now
we see all the template we see the
template but it is looking
bad
so this is because we have not set up
our static files
our static files is basically any other
file
that we're going to use in our template
file so any other apart from my html
this might be an image file a javascript
file or css file any other file we're
going to use
in this our template it needs to go into
static and we're gonna do that in the
next session
so as i said the reason why our template
is not looking good right now is because
we haven't connected or set up our
static files let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to come back to visual studio
code
the static files as i explained in the
last video is basically
any other file that we're going to use
in our template file apart from the html
file so any other image css for
javascript file any other file we're
going to use goes to the static but how
do we set this up let's do that
so let's close out this again
and similarly to what we did in the last
video we're also going to create a new
folder name is static
and as you might have guessed we're
going to go into the settings of pyr
file also
and then we're going to set static up
right here it just shows this that the
static url but we need to set up the
static root and the static files
directory so let's do that
so static
underscore root
goes to os dot
path dot join
is there
static files
i don't mind why this is different from
this
but this the next one now is the main
connection so says static
files
there's
first two
is
the path
the join
is there
comma
static
right here
now let's save this
now let me quickly take a moment to
explain why we're even doing this
so jungle whenever we're connecting
like images or css files it doesn't
connect it the normal way that html
connected so if you work with html very
well you know that when you want to link
for example an image file
what we do is
you have an image
and we say src
equals to then right here
we have like the
directory to the image file in my bin
assets
slash
image.jpg
so for example in
html these i will link an image file but
in django is quite different
what we just need to do in jungle
we need to make sure that this asset
slash image file is inside the folder
named static so it must be inside this
folder and after it's been inside our
folder when we are going to the html we
need to put something like this and say
with a percentage sign we say static
with this
that to close
so this is the way jungle basically sees
any external file and we're gonna do
this for anytime we are linking to any
standard file it might be css it might
be javascript images any other file but
this is what we're gonna do
so for django to be able to recognize
this we need to set all these things up
like setting up static creating a new
folder and putting the static files in
there i hope you understood what i just
now i can just close that up and save
so now that we have all this set up
next thing we want to do is to move copy
all our static folders and files into
this static folder right here
gonna come into
well
first of all in this template
right here
this asset is where all the static
for all those html is located
external files for all these files
in this asset that means we just need to
drag the asset
into this static folder and
do not add folder to workspace copy the
folder
so i copied it we've copied it there but
as i said the profile
and the rest have different
settings or different files either so
what we just want to do now
also copy all the static
steps
yes store
and just select that out
and now let's copy the rest
attic
opening food
now everything is going to copy it's
just going to take a few seconds because
some files might be larger than the
other so that's
done and we actually do not need this
so we have seen
okay this is still
okay but as that is doing
we're gonna close this settings now we
don't need it
and we're gonna actually open this
index.html file right here in the code
editor
i'm going to come to template and open
index.html
we're going to get back to this also
let's just make sure all this has worked
i have one two three four five six seven
for the profile
so
seven items selected good but we don't
need a static down template it's not
part i just added that so we're gonna
have to
kind of remove that
contempt
go
delete it
equipping
so you don't need to understand what i
did there what i just did was i added a
file that i want to remove basically
so now as you can see
this html5 is quite different because on
top we have something named load static
right here remember what i explained
when i said we don't link files normally
so just to save time
and not
let you watch
hours of tutorial on something not
necessary so i already you know
configured all the linking for the way
jungle will see it like django template
and stuff so before you can do this
before you can even like go to a css
file and add a static and also close it
at the top of the file
you need to add something named load
static
if we don't add this it's going to give
us an error it's basically loading all
the static settings the static file so
this file can use it so i already did
all this for all the wall
you know
html files are copied so
that's why if i come back here
if i come into template
i come into so you can see i said static
non-template i have the normal template
that doesn't have all these
configurations done but before i started
filming this tutorial i just made sure i
you know tweaked everything so that
it will save time but i hope you
understand what i mean by this static so
basically we need to load static first
of all and then
anywhere we are linking something we
just need to add this static at the
beginning and at the end so throughout
the whole file i did that anyway we are
linking a file i added everything if we
scroll all the way to the bottom
writing the javascript also i did that
so that's just how to
configure that and if we scroll up
and notice that right here we are
linking a png
but
we didn't add static let's add static
piece
and we close it like this
that's basically how to do it
now if we go into our
browser
and we hit that refresh button
see our website in good
let's see
second
things
the color
yeah boom as you can see right now
basically have all of this loaded
everything good
such username the post is as you can
follow so this is just the basic
template i used for this as you can see
everything is fine the static files have
been loaded
load more javascript is also working so
everything is totally good
so now that we have all of this
let's just try ahead
by
starting with the registration and
signing up of a user
now let's start with the authentication
of our website so
basically what i mean is allowing a user
to register and login to our website
so before we do this
we need to create a model so first of
all let's
close this index.html we don't need it
for now and then we're going to come
into
modules.py right here
so this models.py file is basically the
file where we create our jungle models
so we can use it as a database for our
project
so now we want to create a profile model
this profile module is going to have
different things like the user profile
picture
the user bio the user location and stuff
like that so
first of all let me explain why we are
creating this profile module
so we know that django as
in as default it gives us this user
model which a user is going to be able
to you know sign in sign up and have
some information like their first name
username email and stuff but we want
more
so the jungle
alt user model authentication it gives
us the username
the first name last name email and
password so those are the only fields it
gives us but we want more so we want to
be able to add the user by you the user
profile image the
location maybe like a country is from or
something so there are various ways we
can go about this we can create a custom
user model or we can just extend
that user model that jungle already
gives us or we can create a separate
model for the profile
and link it to user model using a
foreign key
so that's what we're going to do i'm
going to create a separate model for the
profile and link it to the user model
using a foreign key so i'm going to show
you how we're going to go about this now
you might want to do it anyhow you like
if you're already familiar with jungle
you might want to extend the database or
anyhow you feel it's easier for you
but this is the way i'm going to do it
in this tutorial
so first of all
let's create
a class and we're going to name it
profile
and that will be take from the models
dot model
and now i want to give this field the
user
just pass on everything first
i want to have like the id of the user
so
now i'm not going to say user underscore
id and i'm going to explain what i'm not
going to say it's why i do id user
so we have user this is going to be a
foreign key that is going to link to
that model i'm going to we're going to
do that the id user this is going to be
the id
of the user that has this profile
and we also want to buy you
we want
profile image
profile img
pass again
we want the location
so these are basically the things we
want for this our modules
but for this profile image we're going
to use an image field so if you're
familiar with jungle you know we have
different model field we have character
field the text field integer field but
when we want to do something like a
profile image we can use the file field
but that file will be able to call it
like videos pdf files or we want to
narrow it down to
but this view to connect all the images
so we're going to use an image view
so what we're going to do is something
like this models
dot
image
field
now we need to configure some things
like where will this image upload to
when a user uploads the image
which folder will you upload to
so just the way we set up static files
and all those type of stuff we also need
to set up media the media is gonna
like take care of uploading like
basically the storage where all these
files are gonna be stored because also
when we go deeper into this application
when we allow a user to upload a post
the user will want to upload an image
with that post so where would that image
go to so we need to store we need to
configure all these things also and this
one is quite different from the others
the only similarity is that we are going
to create
a new folder again in the base directory
as i said the page directory is the
folder which contains the money.py file
of that project
so now we're going to create a new file
i'm going to name it
media
this media basically is going to store
all the images we're going to be
uploading
and now that we've created that file we
need to come into
our settings dot py so i'm going to open
our proof our project
and go to settings
now right here we just make sure we
scroll down
and we'll say media
underscore url
a
flash media
flash
dash like this
and we also need to specify the media
routes
the os dot
path the join
based directory
and
media so the name of this folder must
correlate with the name we gave it here
let's save that and we can quit this the
next thing we need to do is to go into
the urls of py file of our project not
of our app so we need to come into
social cookie's main project go to the
urls of your wifi
all right here we're going to import two
things
i'm going to import settings and static
if from
jungle
and configuration we shorten it to conf
import
settings
next one is from
jungle.configurations.urls.static
import
static
good so this is what we need to import
and now to specify the url for this our
media
specify or to configure our media url to
finalize it the urls patterns
goes to
variable pattern above
plus static
settings
dot media
underscore url
have a comma
and just bring it down here
and say
document
underscore root
equals to settings
dot media
root
now we can save this
so what this is doing is it's just
specifying the url
of our media so uh media files so this
is just the way we set up anything
dealing with media let me quickly recap
so we we started with our modules which
we are going to finish in a minute
but because we are going to use an image
field and that is a file
we need we need to create a new folder
called media which is going to take care
of the uploading of the image where it's
going to be stored and we need to go
into settings.py file to
assign these two variables media url
media root and we needed to import that
into the url.py file socialbook
and just
configure url path
now we can close this and now we'll be
able to use
an image field in our module
so now
we say models.image huge
but one more thing we need to specify
some things that django is going to
understand so
when a user wants to submit a form of
this field or when he doesn't want to
submit a profile image
where does that image upload to i know i
said it's going to upload to the media
folder or where in that media folder is
it going to upload
so we want to have different categories
or different folders under this media
folder here so we might have one that
says profile images my vendor folder
that say post images so we don't mix all
the images together so let's say
this should upload and use the upload
tool
profile
images
now i know that under media folder we
don't have any older name profile images
but if we don't have any folder what
django is going to do is that for the
first time it's going to create a new
folder there called profile images and
then from that time
any image being stored through this
field or through this model is going to
be stored under media on a profile image
so basically since we don't have that
created now we can create it manually
but i prefer for django to do it
automatically so you're just going to
create profile images folder and it's
going to store it today
but now that we have that out of the way
one more thing
so you know when you sign up to like
facebook and you don't yet have
a profile picture there's actually a
default profile picture that facebook
puts for you
so we also want to do that so that if
the user doesn't have a profile picture
yet want to give him a default profile
picture
but what we're going to do now right
here if you come into your static
and you come into images
you're going to see that we have a image
called blank profile picture
that's the name of the image blank
profile picture dot png
i would love to show you yeah if that is
going to open but that's just basically
a default profile picture that we're
going to give the user so okay that's
going to open good as you can see this
is just a default like profile picture
for user that didn't upload the profile
picture yet
so now let's just
copy the name of that file
and quit this
and then what we just want to do is to
say
default equals to
blankprofilepicture.png
but remember again i said that anything
dealing with these images
of files in a jungle model it needs to
be done in this like media folder so
when we are getting the default image
this blank profile picture.png how does
django know that it's supposed to go
into static images then look for this no
jungle doesn't know that so what we are
going to do these blank profile images
we're just going to drag it
from there and paste it in media
don't want to move that so now it's the
media so when
we say blank profile picture that image
tango is going to go into this media
folder and look for that file
since now that we know django can see
that file we can continue with
configuring the rest of our module files
our model fields this profile image now
is done model dot image field
it's uploaded to profile images and it
defaults as if the user didn't upload
profile image yet
or doesn't want to upload the profile
image you should just use this as the
user's profile image
so now that we have that out of the way
let's start from the beginning right
here
so here in this user
we want to link this particular profile
to the user model
using a foreign key so what we need to
do first is to get the
model of the current user that is logged
in or that is authenticated
and then that is going to be
like
be the default for this foreign key so
we are going to understand that now when
we do that
first of all let's do from
django.contrib.org
on trip
dot auth
import
get user model so i want to
import this
attribute name get user model but you're
just going to get the model of the
currently authenticated user so let's
give it
variable and say user equals to
get user model
we're just initiating that
and now that we say user equals to this
get user model
anytime we use this user now is just
basically going to be
model of the currently logging user
so now right here we're going to say
models
dot foreign key
user
on delete
first modules
cascade
that's good so now what this is just
doing is we have a foreign key that is
linking to the
connector to this user which is
this user variable which is this get
user model
that's been imported
you have that done now this id user is
just meant to be an integer field so
model
dot
integer field
that's that's that doesn't need any
attributes in here
so i know you might not understand why
we like have this id user or while we
have
this user foreign key
related to a foreign key that is
connected to this that if you are new
you might not understand that but when
we are using this in our you know
project when we are getting the post
when we are allowing the user to be able
to follow another user you know why or
you understand why all these
are being done like this so just follow
along for now and let's get back so
now we have the bio the bio we just want
the bio to be a text field
so same model the text field
and
we can give it blank equals true now
this is because the user might not want
to have a value it's not compulsory and
allow it to be blank
now the location
models dot character field this time
around and a character field
has a max length
of hundred
i just give it a maximum length of
hundred and let's also give it blank
equals true because the user might not
want to put his location that's not
compulsion
all this is good
we have the user
id of the user the value of that user
profile image the location
now let's just return
the
basically the username
so say dev
str
self
return
self.user
so this self.user is just this let's get
the username that model
so what this is doing this is not
compulsion you can remove these if you
don't want this is just in the name of
the model so that when we are seeing the
model in our admin panel it's going to
be showing the username and it's not
going to be showing object 1 or object
2. i'm going to show you that like in a
couple of seconds
so now we have this done
now let's just go back to our command
prompt and let's make migrations and
migrate everything to our database
first of all note that before you
run migrations or anything the app where
you have this module.py for us it is
core that's the name of the app this app
must be added to install apps in the
settings of your wifi if we come down
here remember in the beginning i said
let's just add this to avoid any error
later that is the main reason so because
we want django to be able to see this
app as part of this project we need to
add it to installed apps so now we
can be able to
upgrade our database
so basically if you don't know the
meaning of migrate or what i'm talking
about in jungle once we create all this
data here so this is basically like the
name of the database and these are
tables in the database so think about it
like that this is the name and these are
tables but these are row each row
each row like this
i wish i can like visualize this for you
in a table but just think about it like
this the name of that database and this
is each row in the table of that data
so now all this that we've done we need
to migrate it to our database i'm going
to show you that also so we have to come
right here
let's opt out of the server real quick
out
so yeah done and now to migrate our
server we just manage
python
manage dot py make migrations
and once we make migrations what this is
doing is that any changes that we made
in our models dot py file is gonna save
that change before migrating it to our
database so if we come here and let's
say we add
blank equals false or something blank
doesn't have a false but if we remove
blank or something since we've made it
change we need to come here and do
python manage write make migrations to
save that change then migrate again
anytime you touch this file you need to
do that it's just
that
now that that changes has been
made let's just say
python manage dot py
migrate
so now this is going to migrate that
database
that model into our database this is the
first time we're running it that's why
it's migrating the earth admin and every
other thing but the main thing we want
to see
migrating is this call that's my great
thing
and
now
um i want us to run our project and go
to the admin to see our
you know database but we can go to the
admin to see our database because
if we go there we don't have any login
yet
that a user can use to
log into the admin panel so to create
that we're going to say python
manage
dot py
create
super
user
this command line is going to create a
super user now this super user means
like
a user that can access the admin panel
so any normal user that sign up from our
site can just use their login details to
log into the admin panel only we
developers that can create a specific
super user and log into the admin panel
so now let's just say admin
give it
book
dot com
i'll give you the password password
again
it says the password is to come on to
the username let's just bypass that but
that is created successfully now let's
run our server again
ui run server
but that is preparing to run i'm going
to come back into our browser
actually let's open a
private window this private window is
just for our admin panel so that we'll
be able to log into our admin panel and
not
interfere with logging in
to a normal user so
it is
in private browsing
and go to our website now
slash admin our website should be
running now
just come here and see
so as you can see right there our
website is running
let's come down good this is what we
want to see
it basically gives us this
login form to log into the django
administration now django administration
doesn't have a signup form
the only way you can sign up to this
generation is from your console it's
from your command line
now let's log in with the details we
just created
i mean
again with the password also
and we hit again
good but now that we use login you can
see we have just two
database we have groups and we have
users this is created by default
in django
if we open these users we're going to
see one user which is us the
super user admin user so let's wait for
that so as you can see the username
admin email address
and staff status so remember i said that
django as a default gives us this user
model but it doesn't have enough fields
for us to build this social media
platform it just gives us only username
email address first name last name
and a password but we want more than
that as i said so that's why we created
a profile model now let's go back to our
visual studio code because
we come back to home you see that the
model we just created which is profile
is not showing here so we also need to
make sure that that shows here so we can
manage that database
do that it's very simple just like two
lines of code
we come into a file named admin.py
now this file is going to be in your app
just click on the file
and the first thing to do right here is
to import the model that you want to
show
in your admin panel
if from dot models
import profile since this profile we
want
show in our admin panel or register to
administer
now say admin
dot site
does register
profile
now i register now
it's profile mode into the admin if i
save this now
just gonna come back here and make sure
everything loads successfully
once that loads i'm gonna go back to my
admin panel and now i should see my
profile
done
i'm gonna come here
if i refresh this now good now i see
under this core app see profiles right
click on it no profile yet because we've
not done anything to the profile but
this is the first step in the user
authentication
so
i hope you understand what we've done
till this point created a specific
profile model for each user so when
users sign up
a profile mode is automatically going to
be created for them now we're going to
do the
registering of a user of the signing up
of the user in export
the next thing to do now is to set up
the view for
our registration
to be able to register a user into our
platform basically
what we want to do now
let's just come into views.py
we want to create a new url for our sign
up
so let's just collapse these
and this
just to make everything clean
first of all we're gonna have to come
into urls and create a new url
for that view so what we want to do want
a user to be able to come to our website
slash sign up and you'll be able to sign
up to our platform or register on our
platform
so let's add it here
right now just put sign up
and right here sign up
and the name also should be sign up
so basically
our website slash sign up then you
should go into views dot sign up and it
has a name of sign up but we know we
don't have user sign up yet we're gonna
have to come into views
create a new function named sign up
it's gonna take a request
and let's just render
our html template return render
request
sign up.html now this signup.html
basically
this page is signup.html
that's what we are rendering when user
goes to slash signup
let's save this
also save our urls
basically we have that done
and let's just make sure that when we go
to slash sign up it really renders this
first of all
as you can see right here our website is
running so we can go test that out
now let's go to slash sign
up
enter good so as you can see our website
is showing and we
are going to do some configurations
first of all
we
want this to be sign up on the changes
to sign up once it changes to social
book and maybe change the title let's go
do that first
we will come back here
and then in
signup.html
so this again remember as i said i
already tweaked the
all the links for static
so now i'm just gonna
change this to
up
okay
okay and let's scroll down
right here where we see
youtube
social
book
all right here we see signing we have to
change it to sign
up yeah so that's that
and
this
could be
fine
let's just
use changes
sign up social work social book sign up
this is i know
we change this instead of this so
to see with that
then right here which is sign
up
that should work now
i know about this was logging good
now once that to be able to sign up with
just the username
the
email and the password we don't really
need the first name if you want to
collect the first name in your own
application you can do that but we don't
really need the first name and last name
let's just call it the username the
email and
because user have to have a password
right here where we see
this
form
let's just image this for rest
make
our work
we have this form here
what we're gonna do is
a name let's change it
and let's make it have
so we have all this style and everything
done
let's just
username is okay
let's have an email type should be an
email
this order should be email
and
all of them needs to have a name
because when we are collecting the data
in our back end
we're going to collect them using the
name
of the particular thing
so right here after
type
the name
so this is the username should have name
of username
so let's just copy this
you have email
and this is what the password right so
password
and this is
as you say password to
confirm password and we can also change
this to password the type
your password type
more security
and what again i agree to terms and
condition that is not really
let's just comment that out
now let's go ahead and see what we have
now
so it automatically fuse it in
basically
let's just remove that
hdd
it doesn't fill it in again
now we have sign up we have all of these
which is good
what we want to do let's also scroll
down
button
everything is working
good
so now right here in this form we want
the action
we leave it blank now when we leave this
action blank it means that once we hit
sign up all this data that has been
inputted in here is going to be sent
back to the signup page i'm going to
show you why we do that
so now we have the action blank
another thing we want to have
is the method
we want to use a post method now in
django there are
two different
type of methods we use when submitting a
form
use the guest method and the post method
let me tell you why and when we use any
of the two
we use a guest method basically when we
are passing
like an information that is not
confidential so like let's say a user
wants to search like
python you have a search engine here and
the user also search like python
so on that search form
you can use a get method because the
value being shown
is not confidential it's just what the
user is searching for
and when you're asking the post method
is basically where when you have
confidential
inputs like a password we don't want the
password to show so if you use a guest
method whatever is being searched or
whatever it means submitted is going to
be shown in the url we've used a post
method those values are going to be
hidden
those are the major two difference
so
if we're going to show an input in the
url that input has to be an input that
is basically not confidential as i said
because if we are using
like this signup form and why is in a
get method we don't want to show the
user sign the user's password in the url
bar that is not a good practice so
that's why we use post method or let's
say you have a
platform where a user pays using his
credit card information
and you don't want to use a guest method
in that situation because credit card
information can be shown in the url so
basically those are the majors to
difference you can also
do a quick search on google if you want
to dive deeper that
another thing is that when we use a post
method in django
we need to add this
templating style called csrf token now
this just take care of some what malware
because this dsrf stands for cross site
request for audrey so it's basically
like an attack but when you put this it
basically takes care of that
jungle way we're not going to get too
much
into that
now let's save this
and let's come here and hit refresh
and
just put
random things
just to make sure that everything is
working
once we sign up it brings us back to
this page that's what we want
so now that all this information is
being sent to sign up view using a post
method
what we're just going to do now
in the views
we're going to get all of them using an
if statement so what we're going to say
is that
if requests does method
equals to post
so this simply means that if the
when a user wants to
look for this site or when user comes to
this particular page
if this page has been summoned using a
post method then we're going to do a
pool of things if not just show
sign up so when we just come to this
page normally and just enter like this
it's just a it's not a post method yet
so but when we submit a form i need to
sign up we are
sending back some information to this
page using a post method that's when
we're going to be able to get those
values
so what we're going to do now
that if the request of meta disposed
we're gonna do some things let's pass
first
else
i mean there's not a post method and
just
on this particular
page so now there is a post method let's
get all the value that has been sent to
this
view
so we can get that same
name
first to request
let's post
their name
what i just did was that i added a new
variable and i said request.post
username that means the the data that
has been posted here is going to get the
value of that data using the name of the
input if i come back to sign up
remember i said they have to have a name
when this is submitted it's going to
have like a name and a value so using
the name of this input which is username
now
in this views file we'll be able to get
the value now if we just do something
like print
username
it's going to basically print whatever
we input here in our console just give
me a minute and let's just add something
and um just fill it up and test what i
just said
so as you can see it's not yet getting
any error like the password don't match
um
all this type of stuff like the username
is taking the email is taking we're
still going to do that but now we hit
sign up
let's see
gives us a value error
they said views dot signup didn't return
so it didn't return anything because
we're not returning i'm not giving it a
response we're just getting the value
but we're going to undo that but let's
come back here first and you'll see
that right here
gives me this value which i put in the
form as the username basically we are
getting the value of that form
and once we have the value that is being
sent to that form and just use that
create a new object in our user model
now let's go back here
and what we're just going to do is to
copy this four times
so now we need to have email
password and password two which is
repeat password
so now the email
has a name of email
just advisable to copy it so you don't
contain any error in the names and stuff
like that even if you know you are
correct
password
password two
now we have all these values
now that we have all these values
and create
now first check some things we first
check if the password one is because of
the password two because
when was saying confirm password the two
passwords have to be the same we also
check if the email exists we also check
if the username exists
before we do all those we need to import
something and what we need to import is
the user model
user model which is
um
right here
which is this user model where all the
users has been stored
so we need to import that right here
so
first of all
let's say
from
tango
dot contrib
that's earth
that's models
import
user
good i also want to import something
named alt now this is going to allow us
to authenticate the user
now i think that's what we need for now
just come down here back
so now
this
is we're just gonna have another if
statement
and yeah what i'm gonna say is
if
password
equals to password two
and if the passwords are the same
then
something
fast for now
else
we'll have to give it an error
saying that the password does not match
so to give an error we're going to use
something called messages we also need
to import that
so we have to scroll all the way up
right here where we have
we could have imported it from this
let's just
angle
dot contrib
import
messages okay so this is going to be
able to send a message if it's an error
or a warning
just gonna be able to send a message to
the front end
so now
if the password is equals if the two
passwords are the same we're gonna
continue and will not check again if the
email is taken or use any mistake but
before we even go for that if the
passwords are not the same let's first
send an error and tell the person that
the passwords
don't match
we're going to say messages
let's use an info
message is the info
the request
and we just turn the message
password
not matching
and then
we have to redirect the user back to the
sign up page
but before we even use redirect we also
need to import redirect but that's easy
because we are importing redirect from
django.shortcut which we already have
here so let's just say redirect
now that we have that we just say return
direct
to the sign up
so we are redirecting the user to the
sign up
by sending this
message so that the user will be able to
fill that form again basically
now that we have this as if the password
are not equal but if the password is
equal
let's have another statement by saying
if
user which is the user model
dot objects
dot filter
email
equals
email
dot exists
i want to do something so what this is
saying is that if
we go to the user model we check each of
the objects then we filter and we find
an object in which the email which is
being
which is in the user model is equal to
the email which is being
posted to this view if that exists then
we just want to tell the user that this
email already exists i mean this email
is already taken the message is dot info
request
email
taken
and then once we tell the user that
email is taken we want to redirect the
return
redirect
user to the sign up
now that we have that
we will use another if state member a
leaf so else if
we want to check if the
username is taken so say user
dot objects dot filter
name
goes to username
but exists
and we just want to do the same thing by
saying messages
that's info
request
username
taken
and then we're gonna
direct the person back to this page
so now
for what if
password is equal
the
username does not exist and you and the
email does not exist
just say else sometimes if there is no
error nothing but happen what we just do
now we want to create that new user so
we just say user
equals to user
dot objects
dot
create
user this one this one is going to be
able to create a new user for us
and we just say user name
goes to this username that has been
passed
and then the email
equals to the email that has been passed
and also the password of that user
we just take one password because we
don't need to sort to passwords
just to pass
so we're storing the username
password
and the email basically
now that we have that
just say
user
dot save
now that we save the user
this should work
but before you know saving the user or
doing anything like that before testing
it
as i said we created this profile model
so once we create a new user we also
want to create a profile model for that
user but before we test that out let's
just save this first of all
and let's go to our
page
and we have this one
so what we want to do now we want to
test the error that
we
configured in here remember we said if
password is not equal it should give an
error so let's even test if that is
working
so our
that is
okay good
so now
that
um give it this
i'll give another one
okay so when i sign up now
if i come into
my users
you'll see that there's no
additionalization
and this is because obviously the
password was not the same so it can
create a two different password but
didn't even tell us anything like the
password is not matching i didn't create
or whatever how would the user know what
happened so we need to do that
what we are going to do is to go into
the html file here we are going to use a
for loop
we are just basically going to pass
those messages that has been sent
and show it here like password no
matching or password correct or username
taking and stuff like that let's quickly
go back to our vs code
but since we are sending all these
messages already
writing them to redirect it should be
easy
what we just want to do
from above
form
let's have a new div tag
in there we want to have
say
for message
in
messages
and h5
let's just
print that message
this is just going to basically print
the message for us
let's end our for loop
but we want this to show like an arrow
so it should be like a color red or
something and it should be bold or
something like that
so let's have a styling
now
right here we can just say h5
let's give an initial
color of red
let's save that
and
very loose good so we refresh that page
and the data we posted before was
reposted back as you can see now it says
password not matching if we try to
create let's say admin because we
already have a username admin if you
tell us username
taken
let's just give it blank
let's make sure this
name
nice it gives the username taken because
the admin
taken so as you can see now the error is
being cut successfully what we want to
do now
if we make sure that there's no error
that means a new username email and
password is going to create a new user
for us in here
but we don't want to do that yet because
if we create a new user now only the
user object is created but a profile
just won't be created for that user so
let's go back to our code and make sure
that
once a user is created right here
once we have a new user created we also
want to create
a new profile
let's say a new profile object for that
user
so
first thing we're going to do let's log
the user in
it will say
the user no we're not going to log the
user in first of all
the first thing i want us to do
okay so before we log the user in i'm
not going to log design yet
that's because
when we log the user in i want the user
to be automatically redirected to like
the settings page where you can upload
profile and put this by you and location
but since we don't have that yet
let's just create a profile model for
that user first
before then when we have the settings
done we can come back and change that
so let's just
have a comment here and say
user in
and
direct
to
settings
page
so we don't forget about that and now
right here let's just create
a profile
object
for the new user
we're going to do now is say user
underscore module
user.object
dot get
that name goes to youtube
what i'm doing now is that
first of all because in here also create
a new profile we need to give that
profile the user that owns this profile
if that user will be able to give it
this value we need to have the object of
the user we don't just need to have the
username or the id of the user we need
to have the object of that specif
now what i'm getting now i'm saying the
user model should be user the object.get
the one which the username is equals to
the username that was just created right
now
and then once we have that with the new
profile
and the equals to profile
dot objects
dot create
user
because to the user
model
and also the id of the user
once you get the id of the user
id user was what we used
and we equals to the user model dot id
so these are the only two things we want
to give as default
come back here
to our modules
gave it this value the user
object and we gave you the idea of use
so the biography the
profile image and the location the user
is going to create that
stuff
so now
let's just save this user basically and
analyze the creating of
the
profile model
so we just say
new
profile
let's save
then
and just redirect the user
the login page
but right now we don't have a login page
so
since we don't have a login page
i'm gonna be able to
i'm not gonna be able to redirect the
user anywhere so let's just redirect the
user back
sign up when we create a login page
we're going to be able to direct the
user
so let's save this now
once we have this saved now we can come
project
that
let's make sure our project
yeah
good
so since it's running now let's create a
new utah let's say john
let's give him a password
let's sign him up
it gives us
name error
now this is because it said name profile
is not defined and this is because we
are using this profile name but we
didn't import it right here so we need
to import that profile model
from the py file if from
dot models
import
profile
good this should work now
if we come back in here
done
energy.com
in my password
now it's sign up
so it says email taking now this is
where the error comes because we
tried to create
a new user so we created a new user
for right now when it says name profile
not defined
the error was here that profile was not
defined but that didn't stop that from
creating a new user the new user was
already created but the profile object
was not created for it
so this is just what's in the testing
phase so right now
we come back here
and it's refresh see john as a new user
and as you can see is not a staff this
stuff means he can't access this admin
panel come into profiles see that we
don't have any profile right here but we
are supposed to have a profile for john
this was because
john was already created before we fixed
the bug about the profile name not
defined so now let's delete john first
of all
now let's try to
login again good i refresh that page
once i refresh that page from this
button
it's going to send that post data again
but if i refresh it from here just gonna
load the page normally so since opposite
i was sent the game
john
user is now created and jump profile
model is now created so let's go check
that
hit refresh
so it didn't create it if i come to
profile also didn't create it that means
when i hit refresh didn't submit that
post again normally in like normal
browsers like i think chrome once you
hit refresh you're supposed to submit
that again but i'm using microsoft edge
this video so i think that's why it
didn't work but let's just quickly go
ahead and
that
energy.com
password
sign up
good
let's just
save it here so we have this sign up
done
normally you know it's supposed to like
take us to the login page to log in or
you just automatically authenticate us
into the platform but since we've not
yet done all those stuff
we just made it redirect back to this
page first of all but since we came out
to this page without an error we should
be expecting now that the user and the
profile object has been created if we
come back here
come to users
see now that we have user john
johnnergy.com
come to profile code we have a new
profile for john
that is good
so the user is basically this done user
and this is the id of the user
so
also
we're going to be able to allow them to
update that bio update our profile image
and location as you can see as a default
the profile image is blank profile
picture.png
is this that we gave it
good that's working fine
everything is fine to this point right
now
next step is to be able to allow the
user
login into our platform
now let's create the login view for our
application
i want the user to be able to go to
slash sign in
and then the user should be able to sign
in to the application
let's go back to vs code
but now let's just
collapse this
right here in urls let's create a new
view i will name it sign in
let's just take that copy it
paste
paste
right here also
open this again scroll down and create a
new view
cdf sign in
quest
return
render
sign in dot html
now that we have this
let's first of all go ahead and collapse
this let's save this
and let's also save this
so now once a user goes to slide sign in
we should have that
so let's
go test that out
sign in
good so it gives us this let's also you
know tweak this very well for everything
to work good
and we'll come back here
but before we even do that let's go back
to the sign up page and you know once i
use that clicks on this login let's take
this out to the sign in view and also
right here
if we go to
sign up before we have login let's say
f
to search and search for
login
so do you have an account this should be
to
slash
sign in
or the second one
is right here
at the top right corner of our
application
let's take them to slash sign in
good
now we have this if we come back and hit
refresh
now it says do you have an account if we
click login it takes us to login good
now let's open up our login page
sign in right here
and then where we have sign in
let's sign into sociopoo
and let's scroll down
on the changes also to social book
it and what else so this is login login
let's create an account and register
want to change create an account and
register
to
make it go to
the sign up view the register
go to the sign up
flash sign
up
now
create an account goes to
sign up
good so this is done
let's come back in here and hit refresh
to share book
now
let's just
you remember me
you are not really using that
this video so let's just comment that
out too
good now what we just need is
to
you know configure this make it have a
post method and all those fun stuff
first of all as i did last time let's
just leave a space
in our form just to finish it and right
here let's have a name
name
and this is the password if i
type of dish
password
and the placeholder i would love it e
password
good
now this is working fine let me save and
see
sending password and each of them have a
name now so the action should come back
to this plugin view
and
method
repost
as i said whenever we use a post method
we need to add
csrf token
good
now that we have this
once a user hit submit or login
send that to our login view let's see
is
we have this
again
okay so
that's basically because we didn't
refresh the page so let's refresh this
yes
anything in there login okay so it just
comes back here which is what we want
and let's do a similar approach to what
we did in our sign up so right you know
sign up now
login view i'm just going to say i'm
going to leave an if statement again
just like we used earlier so let's just
say
if request
method
equals to post
we're gonna do something
else
just return this page
this is what we want to do now
and this is quite easy what we just want
to do is we get the username and
password
just to request
dot
post
name
and copy and paste this
password
it is pasted
right now
what we want to do is to create a new
variable and say user equals to earth
dot authenticate
onto authenticate with any
post
name
password
goes to password while dedicating with
username and password
good
now that we have that
initialized use an if statement will say
if
user
is
not
none
what this mean is that
if the user is not known
so
for this to be able to work that means
we need to even have a user
with this password in our database so if
we have it that means if it's not none
that means
if is
there if he's
present in our database and let's just
authenticate and say alt
dot login
take a request
i want to log in this user
i'll say return
direct
to the home page so now when we log the
user in we want to return to that to the
home page
else
now this just simply means that if the
user is none that means if he's not
you know
he doesn't
really have an account and he's trying
to log in with a credential
then the message error so the messages
that info
request
let's say
again
girls
invalid
and then we just redirected yeah let's
copy from here paste so we're just
redirecting the user
back to this sign-in page
did so
for
need
everything is working here if this
if it's the post method get it
initialize the authenticate
the auth and
check if the user is not known then
authenticate if it's none give him an
error
and yeah now let's save this and we also
have to come into our signing to add
the
gift tag that is going to take care of
the error messages so we can just come
down here and copy that
basically the same thing
sign in
save
you come here
to sign in and we say
if something that is not
in our database
as soon as it says credential invalid so
that's an invalid credential but it
really gives something that's in our
database which is done
and see now
it is authenticating and boom it takes
us to the home page so this is working
fine and and once a user authenticates
it takes user to the home page now we
want to do two more things we want the
user to be able to
log out so once these are coming and
click logout that should be able to log
out and normally be authenticated
and also
we wanted that where user can access
this page the user must be logged in if
user tries to
come to this page when it's not logging
in to be directed to the login url i'm
going to show you how to do that
first of all
let's create a new
path for log out
out log out
onto views
f log out
and i take a request also so let's just
close that up so this logout view is
quite easy all we just need to do
here
the auth
a log
out
request
and we now
find
direct
sign in
since we have this now
and just easily come into the index
and search for log out
right here
out
actually where we have log out now
just say
log out
come back in on each refresh
from here
they log out
boom we are logged out and it takes us
to the login page to login
but one more thing want to do as i said
is that if i come to this home page now
you see i'm still able to even access
this home page while i'm not even
logging
we want that to stop so for us to do
this we're going to use a decorator
kangoo has this built-in function
that allows us to basically take care of
this login
like when a user is not logged in or not
authenticated
want to redirect the user to a page
before bringing it back to another
so let me show you what i mean by this
first of all we are going to need to
import something
so let's scroll all the way up
right here i say from
angle
dot country
dot
dot decorators
import
plugin required this login required is
going to allow us to be able to
direct a user to the login page if it is
not logged in onto our csep
as i said also is i want to access this
index page you need to be logged in for
me to do that now you know i can easily
like configure this and say
if user is not logged in or is not
dedicated then redirect the person well
i don't want to do that
so what i want to do
is because that is like
this is a better way to do it just like
a line of code i'm just going to say at
login required
i'm going to specify the login url so
that means
url it should redirect the user into
that is
sign in url
so
if i save this now
and i come here
this home page
as you can see it takes me to this login
because i am not logged in and you see
automatically after i sign in it takes
me to the omp let me go to john
and
okay that was
valid credentials john
so right now i can view this page
one more thing i need to do is to also
put that login required in logout
because a user can be logged out already
and now come to log out
to try and log out so let's just make
sure that the user is logging first
before you can log out so let's just
copy this
that's good to go that's basically how
to do that
and save that
and now we have everything done about
the authentication to this point so now
we can just
log in
good
so to this point now we're able to log
in
so now let's go ahead and continue with
the settings view so this settings view
basically is going to be where the user
can upload or change his profile image
or
you can also like add this bio on like a
location or change it by you on location
so what we want to do first of all in
the urls let's create a new url and
we're gonna name the url
settings
we'll just say settings
and if you take from the views.settings
and name equals settings also views now
we need to come here
and create a new view and let's mw
settings
take a request
and we just render
settings.html which is this page
13.html
so now we can save this but before we
save we also want to give it this login
require decorator and this is because a
user can come to
settings or to change profile image or
something like that if they are not
logged in that's just not possible so we
give it that and let's save it
so now if we go back to
check our application
to be able to go to slash settings
so let's see
settings s-e-t
s
once we come here it should basically
load up that page good so we have this
from here right now
so we're going to tweak this form a lot
we don't need this
we basically don't need most of this
what we just want is
a file field or an image field
the
text field for the bio something like
this and a location field that's what we
want but you know if you want to add
your own customization you can add
anything you want you can allow these
apps to be able to you know update
first name and last name work in a
relationship even all of this but just
for this
tutorial
what we're going to be doing is just
basically the fields we created in our
profile model
which we didn't set so if i come into
model.py you know that we've already set
user and user id for each user but we
haven't set by your profile image and
location so that is the form where user
will be able to you know set all of that
so what i want to do now
i'm going to come to
the sign up
so now once a user
basically is
logged in
so a user creates an account and right
here i said log in user and then
redirect to the settings page so that
one want to do now
so we want to automatically log in that
user and redirect to the settings page
because now if you're following along
you know that once the user sign up
nothing is going to happen it just bring
the user back to this page but what we
want to do is that once the user sign up
it should take the user first of all
automatically log in the user and then
take the user to
settings page let's do that so
say user
underscore login
equals to
auth.authenticate
i want to authenticate with username
password i'm going to give you the
username that just been created
and also password
with the password
that has just been created so now once
we have this we can just use say
odds.login
down here we'll say earth
login
take a request
i want to log in using this login
right here so now it's going to log the
user in and then once it logs user in
it's going to create a profile object
for that user
and after saving that profile object we
want to redirect the user this settings
page
by taking the user to the settings page
and not back to this i know so this is
what we want
so we can just go ahead and close this
up
and if you come to the signing that is
taken care of so once the user is logged
in just take the user to the home page
they can see the post feeds and
so that is done and we can just save
that
what we want to do now
is to come into the settings
and we want to
first of all go to the html page and
change some things in here
so if basically just go into
settings.html
so right here we're going to change some
things we're going to remove some form
tweak some from
and yeah so let's get started with that
so
right here where we have let's see what
we want to remove but we have account
settings we don't want to remove it
actually we just want to add some things
in there so you can see here we have
account settings right here we want to
show like
account setting for this user like maybe
for john which is the user so whichever
user is currently logged in we want to
show so first of all
and we also want to have a link here
where user can go to the home page back
because right now isa can just go it has
to start removing the url bar to go or
pressing back we don't want that we want
a link here that will allow user to go
so we'll come back here
and we have an
a tag
and i should just take user to the boom
i will close it
and say home
save that and come back here
hit refresh so it says um account
settings if i click on this um it takes
me to the um
home page but i want to do something
like home slash account settings so we
know that that's the directory we are in
so let's say um
slash account setting
but now we say account setting
for
then we show the user but that user has
to be in a bold tag
so to show the currently logging user in
the jungle template on the html file
is what we do
you do
we open two curly braces and close it
and we'll say user.username
that's what we do if you want to show
the email which i don't know why you
showed that but we want to show it to
you dot email so let's just hit
refresh button so as you can see there's
home slash account settings for john
rj.com which is the email the user puts
when he was logging in
let's just say user dot username
now we save this it refresh
the account settings for john
and that is good we've done that next
thing we want to do to go back here and
then we are going to scroll down
first of all
all of this ul tag basically don't need
it
just gonna
i mean that out
so i'm actually building this from
scratcher you know you understand
everything that we're going to be doing
here
and after this let's have like
a break just to leave this space
so there's a little bit of space there
unless i have like
a line to demarcate
her
fresh so there's just a line there just
to demarcate this is the title and this
the main page
now that we have this
just close that gap
we're gonna come here in this basic we
want something like general settings so
this should be like the general set
let's just change it to general
and that's done
and now let's tweak the form but before
we even do that we don't need privacy
also so we're going to scroll down
scroll down right here
you see where we have this privacy
so all the way from here
to the end of the privacy div tag
i have to close all of that
so from here
close this
that so now that just basically close
that div tag for us
scroll down
yeah so that's good and if we save it
and go back
you don't have that again because we
don't need it and the next thing we want
to do is to remove first name last name
we want to remove email that about me
want to change it to bio want to leave
location remove working art and remove
relationship so basically just removing
the things we don't need and keeping the
things that we need
yeah
first name
out me we change this to bio
give it an id of bio
aim of bio
actually we can leave the id but what we
need to change is the name
because that we're going to be using to
get
it's in a back end so now the location
we're going to leave that
and what we need to add is the name for
this location so since we have a name
just say name equals location
good come back here and hit refresh we
have value we have location and we don't
need working out and relationship so
working out
relationship
click on
we will remove that
let's save and refresh
it so what we want to have now is
another field for the profile image so
we're going to go
up here
i've
like like this
and then
when i say profile
image
this would be a file field
a name
a profile
let's just give the name image
let's save this
it's refresh
so now we have this
we have the profile image the bio and
the location
so
i'm also also going to do something like
you know when you go to like instagram
and you already have a bio once you come
to the settings you'll see the bio you
already have there so for example let's
say we have a value here
and we hit save
if we hit save and it saves our database
when we come back here we don't see that
by you yet we want to be able to see
that by you so i'm going to do that
later and you're basically going to
understand what i'm talking about when
we do that but first of all since we
have all of this done
let's just make sure we have our form
because all of this needs to be in a
form so we can send it to the view
so right here
that general right
yeah
but we just need to have here now
the form
the form
i'm gonna go ahead and close that form
at the bottom so we using the form
right before this other comment
somewhere
we also have a button to save that
we have this save button here
okay
so we have the save button
button
it should be right here
so let's just leave it down like that
and then since we have this done already
let's just set an action
let's set an action
so as always we wanted to come back here
another method of post
we also need to set up the csrf token
so now that we have all this set up
we in this button here this button
should be
submit button first of all we don't need
this cancel
what or we can do something like once
they eat cancer
take them
to the home page
let's just put that in there
bash
so if they cancel and they don't want to
do that again
look at the
bottom left corner you see that it's
taking them to the home page so that's
what we want
and this save button
type button
actually the type should be submit
just so that it submits this form
now we hit refresh
maybe
okay when it brings back here good so
now all of this is working fine
next step is to go into our views
right here in our views
where we have these settings
we're gonna have to do a little bit of
coding here so what we're gonna do first
of all
we want to get the
particular profile object of this user
of the logged in user the user
profile
goes to profile
dot
objects dot get
user
equals to request
dot user
so basically what this is doing
is saying that we have a new variable
named user profile and the value we're
giving that is
profile.object.get that means we're
getting a particular object
so we're getting the profile object in
which the user
come back here in which the user
is the currently logged in user
rightly authenticated user since we have
that
what we want to do
is to pass the mixture in that
pass that into our html view like this
user profile
and user profile so now that we have
this
if i come into my
html settings.html i can actually do
something now
so
as you know as default a user already
have
like a
profile picture i already have a profile
image that we gave the user winning
first of all from here you'll see that
profile image has a default of blank
profile picture
so
let's use that as a profile maybe we
should be able to tell the user that
there is a profile image here we should
be able to give it like a value a
default value here and if the user wants
to change then you can go ahead and
change and also the same thing if the
user already has a bio you want to show
it here so you can edit or change same
for location we're going to come back to
settings
first of all let's start with the bio
so
we don't have
a value so let's have a value in the bio
i know since this is a text area we
don't put the value here in here we put
the value
so we just use it poly braces and we say
user profile dot bio since we already
sent that from the views
in html it should be fine
so user profile.bio location this is an
input so it needs to have a value if
it's having a value it doesn't need a
placeholder so
let's give value
and let's say user profile dot
location
and this is gonna automatically fill
this place in if the user has a buyer or
location we refresh we shouldn't see
anything yet so we're not submitting it
does it enter won't say anything here
because this user doesn't even have a
buy your location
but now let's come to profile image
first to do this is gonna be
the same actually so what we're just
gonna do is say
after place order or we don't even need
a placeholder i will say value
equals to
userprofile.profile
img now we save this and come here and
hit refresh
now right here we're supposed to see the
current
profile image of the user
but we're gonna fix that again you know
after we do something and i'm gonna also
explain why we do that but first of all
let's leave this like this and what we
want to do
is basically
just come into use
right now once the user hits submit
you want to be able to send all these
data the views update the data or even
create a new data
for that particular user so for this
image
html has this security system that
doesn't
give a default image so that's why we're
not going to be able to use this value
for this image
now i remember working on a few projects
a while ago and we tried to do this but
because html has this
security system as i said that it won't
allow you to put
an image or a default image when a form
loads just you know for some kind of
securities
and that's why we're not going to put
value for that but the other way to go
about this
first of all if there is a user we can
just display
you know the
url here that you already have you a
profile or you want to update or
something or we can just even showcase
the profile image here so let's see
let's see what we can do
and this is not too important but just
to make sure that we do something there
we can have an image
src
and that can be from
profile user profile
dot profile
img dot url so let's make sure we change
it
to dot
let's save this first of all and hit
refresh
as you can see it basically just shows
the current
profile and if we change it
and we're going to change it in a bit
where we change it this should change
also
let's try to
i don't know 25
height
five
i'm just testing the size first
how small okay that's too small so let's
give it like hundred
hundred
okay so that is good now we might you
might want to put it in another way or
any how you want to do it so first of
all let me let's say we should have like
current image or any i want to do but
let's just leave it like this first of
all so this is the current profile image
that is good now what we just want to do
now is to come into the views
and right here in the views we're going
to say
if
request
dot method
equals to post
i want to get something
and what we want to get first of all
once we get if the user actually tries
to update the profile image or not and
this is because in our models we make
sure that
this profile image right here is
compulsory when submitting a new form
we're supposed to have a profile image
so we can say
if
request
dot files
dot get
image
equals to none
so again there are plenty ways you can
do all these things like this is just
the way i i'm going to do it in this
tutorial so what we're just saying now
is that if the request of file.get is
equals to none so that means if there is
no
image being sent
then we just want to
get only
so if we scroll down
here well we just say
they let's even get the image also image
goes to user underscore profile dot
profile image
what this is doing is that if the user
didn't
submit any image it's just getting the
current image that is ready that these
already have and just like submitting
that again basically
so then we are just getting the bio
quest
dot post
i o
and we also do the same
for the location
let's get the location
so now since we have all of this we can
just update the user's profile object
so now
what we want to do first of all because
we already have
a file being sent so for us to have a
file being sent we come into this form
right here
whenever you are sending a file
you need to make sure that you have
another like attribute in here
so what we want to do
because html when and also when working
with django we need to configure some
things like you know when we use post
method we have the csrf token when we're
submitting a file in the form we need to
make sure that we have enc type
and then we'll say multipath slash form
data now this must be there because if
this is not there it's not going to
submit that form it's going to submit
the rest it takes the
the text area all those values is going
to submit them but not going to submit
the image or the file and you must make
sure you have the same
let's just save that now we can come
back to the views
and in here let's just basically say use
the profile dot
profile image
goes to image
do the same thing and say
userprofile.bio
i want to make it equal to bio
also use our profile dot location
make it to be exposed to
location
now that we have all of this
let's just say
user profile dot save
now we've updated
that particular model but what if the
user is submitting an image so
let's say
if request
quest
dot files
let's get
image
it's not equals to none
it's exclamation mark
it is not none
and that means there's something there
so now
since we have that we're basically just
gonna get
that image that these are sent to the
image
equals to
quest and now when we're getting image
if we write in a post method it's going
to be quite different they request dots
get
result files
because we're dealing with files and dot
gets
when you have
a bracket
the image so i want to get the value
sorry that's image
and then we just want to basically do
the same thing for the bio so we just
copy this
so by you adjusting request oppose bio
location request of post location and we
are saying user profile
dot profile image goes to image and the
same for bio on location and then we are
saving it and once we save it
we want to redirect the user
to say return
direct
back to this settings
now
now we have all of this configured it
should totally work
let's go ahead test that out
and come back here
hit refresh
now let's change this profile image
let's see what we can change it to
just allowing that to load up orders
and we have all of these images here
let's just change it to one of it so it
gives it this and let's say bio
i am john
first
nerd
and location let's just say manchester
now we can save once we save boom see it
brings us back to this page but now this
profile image has been updated now the
buyer says i am joined and i am the
coolest net and it gives us okay
sk
doesn't need to be a nerd so we save
that and you can see that also updates
let's come to home
and if i go back to account settings not
sure if i've updated that okay it's just
saying settings.html but if we go
slash settings
you'll see that that bio is there so it
has been saved in our database we have
the location there also and the profile
image saved
so if we come right here
and then we go to john's profile object
what we should see now is john the id is
id is bio
a link to is profile image under
manchester and that thing i want you to
see is how this profile image up uh
uploaded basically so remember that in
here
now models
said you should upload to profile images
as you can see here that's what it did
uploaded to prefer images slash i dot
jpg whatever the name of the file is
so if i come into media now
on social book media you can see now
that i have a new folder named profile
images and in there i have the image
that the user uploaded
basically that's how we can you know
configure these settings
so what we just want to do the last
thing is to come into index right here
we have account setting
i want that to go to slash settings
that should work and we do not need
explore
i'm not also up so let's save this and
come back
here go to home
from here now you should be able to
go to the account settings to see it and
we can change the location let's say it
moved
unless hit toronto
and we save it now
the location is toronto go to home
come back to the account settings
so that is cda basic
and we can also cancel like we don't
want to do it brings us back here
so for now we've been able to
have the account settings for the user
where he can update his bio his location
and his profile image
now let's move to the next step
let's get working with a user being able
to upload a post
the first thing we want to do
is to go into
our models.py file
and right here i want to create a new
model
for the post
to say class post
models dot model
and we wanted to have an id
we also wanted to have
the user
and it should be the user name
i wanted to have
the image which the user is uploading
a caption of that image
created at as a date
posted a name that created that
and the number of likes
so uh giving it all of this
field
and id
we're gonna use the uuid field so first
of all we need to come up
and import
uid
so this uuid just helps us to generate a
unique id
for
you know this particular field for each
of the post and we also want to import
something else want to import date time
so say from
date time
import
date time
so this date time is going to take care
of this created at so it will get the
data that
post was created or uploaded now for the
id let's say models
dot uuid fit
and we'll say primary key equals true
so this primary key question means is
like
this is the id now of this particular
post the identification of each of the
objects now this is because once we have
an id
as a default
jungle creates an id for us which just
has like the first post we have an id of
zero second post one two three and so on
but we want to change that i want to
give you this unique id
so it's gonna have like a long character
but it's going to be very unique i want
to set that to the main id of each of
the objects so it's basically replacing
the initial id when we say primary key
equals true
but anyways anytime we are using an id
field in a django model we need to say
primary key equals true in order to just
give us an error anyway
so now let's say default
pause
uid dot uid4
so now this is what we need we are using
the uuid field primary key is set to
true and the default is guid dot uid4
so now the user this time around we're
not using a foreign key i know he's in
i'm not joining them together what i'm
just going to use is a character field
and this is what is going to go in here
is the username that's the owner of the
post
so let's just say android
and then image
image is going to be an image field
the models dot image
field
upload
to
and then we'll say
let's upload it to
let's say post images the other one
which was this we uploaded it to profile
images but this time around we want to
upload it to post images
they post
underscore images
so that is done
and the next one is caption now this is
just going to be a text field
in models dot text field
and you don't need to put anything in
there created at is going to be a dates
time field we'll say models dots date
time field
right here i'll give a default of date
time equals now
it'll say default
will have to be equals to deep time
close that up
so defaults
date time
equals
that
and now
next one is the number of likes okay
models
that's integer field
i have to give it a default equals zero
because when a user just upload a post
the initial likes number should be zero
and when someone like then it will be
increasing when someone dislikes you to
decrease
so let's just return it in with
close itself
we'll say return
self dot user this time not a
user.username
go to user just because this is not a
foreign key so it's not an object that
has been passed in here philippine
patent here is just the username so dot
user now we can save this
and now that we have this saved we can
just
come into
our command prompt
first of all we want to opt out of a
server that is already running and then
we are going to
make migrations and migrate python
manage dot py
make migrations
so this command line is just gonna as i
said earlier you're gonna change or make
this the changes
save the changes that we made in our
windows or py file it's going to save it
into a file named initial i'm going to
save it into okay so it gives us an
error as no attributes uid field
okay so the error right here is that
this uid field
supposed to be
more better let's just run that again
each of the changes is saved into a
brand new file so if we
come to this file use
yes so zero zero one initial then the
more migrations we make
um
let's just wait for that make migrations
and when we migrate you're going to see
that there's a new file here okay
exactly so we made migrations that
worked a new file is being created it's
just updating it that's the way django
just so you don't really need to
understand why that is that's just the
way django
works with
make migrations and migrate that's what
happens when you run that command
i need dot py migrate
and now this is just going to migrate
into our database for us
very simple stuff
good now let's run our server again
and
that's good so now that we have this in
our
database let's make sure that it's
running so we can go check
before we check let's register this in
our admin panel
to open admin dot py
just say post
post
now that we have that we can close this
up and we can basically just go into our
admin panel right here
and we come to
home
so once we come to home now under core
and that is called app we should see
profiles and we should also see posts
with yes
just
wait for that to load
click on good as you can see now we have
this post
model and this is where we're going to
be storing all the posts that every
single user on our platform makes
so that's good now let's go back in
there
and the next thing we want to do now
is to
go
into urls.py and create a new url for
take care of uploading a post
should be upload
load
upload i will come into our views
on
and just right here we have a new
view a new function
takes a request
and let's just
turn
an http response for now
upload view
we don't just want to leave the response
block so we don't get an error by just
returning an http response and one more
thing let's also add this
plugin required in upload so that a user
can just go to our website
and try to upload or try to you know
send some data to it even
let's save this and let's save this now
that we have that done i'm going to come
into our index.html let me quickly go to
our website
right here where we see upload pics
or videos
so once we click on it it's going to
open this so we want the user to be able
to choose file and we want there to be a
box for caption so you know the user can
see
a caption or see a field where you can
input the caption and they should also
be a submit field
so now let's just go ahead and do that
first of all
we're not uploading videos so we just
changed upload peaks too
that's
but where it is between
peaks
right here changes
it peaks
here also
changes to x
now let's see the next thing we want to
do
so before we even continue i want us to
be able to have like a text around that
area that says welcome user so
the user might be around this area that
can say
welcome like john i think john is the
one logged in now so john we know he is
logged in
and another thing is we want to change
this
particular
icon this is just a default icon now we
want to change it to the
profile picture of the currently logged
in user let's go ahead and do that
now
let's go to where we have this image
what i'm just gonna do
right click on it and i'm going to copy
the image link
i'm going to search for that image right
here but i'm going to
set up
here
good
right here we can see it
what we're looking for
we actually have it in i think 10
different plates
as we can see here so
okay i think this is it so right here
what we just need to do
we need to pass
we need to go into the views of the
index and we need to get the profile
object and then pass it in here
so
we're going to
come into use
right here i'm going to say
user object so let's get the user object
and we'll say user
dot
objects
that get
one in which the username
is equals to request
that user
name
so now we have the object of the
currently logged in user and now we want
to get the user profile object the user
profile
will be equals to
profile
dot objects
dot get
the one in which the user
equals to the user object now i hope you
understand what i did
so first of all i got the object of the
currently logging user now that i have
that object i use it to get the profile
now if we come into models file
we will be able to see that in here
first to get
the particular object with the user we
need to provide the object of the user
since we're using a foreign key
why isn't a foreign camera connecting it
to this user model so to get the objects
a profile object of a specific user we
need to provide the
profile the user object if you
understand we can also drive it another
way we can provide the user id but i
just feel like this is better way
so now that we have the
that profile object what we can just do
is to pass that into our html
just copy this now
let's say user profile
goes to user profile and what this is
doing is i basically just
sending
this variable
of user profile into our html so right
here now if i come to index
and remove this we can access that using
the user profile
the dots and let's see what we use to
save it is profile image
dot profile image dot url
so we use dot url when i want to get the
url of an image view or a file field in
general
now if i save this and i come here
and i hit refresh
but i shouldn't see this image yet good
so i see
the
image of the
currently logged in user if i go to
account settings and change the profile
image
the new profile image
so we have that done the next thing we
want to do is to have the welcome
done or welcome whatever the username is
so we're gonna scroll
up a little bit
first of all
now to some things
so
right from this div
up here
and a comment that out
and also
this
just
as we are going the ones we don't need
what can speed them up
now that we have that
all i just want to do
and it fresh let's see
we have upload page before this upload
peaks we want to have
let's see
i think we can cancel this now
and we have the upload here
so let's look for something
behind it so
let's see please upload uh
for that good so now we are in the form
basically
right here this is the input for the
file
where it says choose
file and
what we can do right now
we need to make sure that this is inside
a form
so we can basically post that form
in there so
up in here
where we see import videos from youtube
that's not here but okay so let's just
scroll up
uh so basically when you have a template
you just
wait to look for how to or where to put
your
form okay so this is please upload uh so
we want to put the formula say around
here before upload peaks
see
okay good so the form should be
here
we have the form here
cut this out
and wherever that div is ending
that is where we're going
he says the div ends here
close it
is actually
that okay so we're closing the
form here we're opening the form here
and this is not part of the can actually
leave this but
age it's maximum
and yes so now all of this is inside the
form now that all of this is inside the
form we can have like an input for each
of them
so what we just want to do
right here
where we have
scroll up a little bit
peaks of videos i'm going to scroll up
to the
pain of the form
so
this
combine that out
and hit refresh
let's see okay
so
you don't need to comment that out
upload peaks
or videos so let's just say upload x
if we say that now we have a file field
is what we want
just hit refresh
make sure everything is working
all right so now we have a file field
which is what we want
and what we're just going to do is to
come here
we're going to remove it from
this custom
div
i'm going to
a from custom
i'm going to save that
and now under here we're going to have
type so from here af class uk text
all right so now what we want to do is
to say
the type of the file
and then
name
equals to
image
underscore upload
so we save that
hit refresh
okay so we have this field now we don't
need this
of all
so it says
choose file which is the image that we
want to upload
and the next thing we want to have is
like a text area
so let's
go back there
so we want to have a text area
beneath
so we can still be inside this div tag
just have
text
area
let's just close
now that we have this
say let's give it a class
button
soft
running and small just give it a styling
fix that in there so now that we have
that we can give you the name and the
placeholder and stuff like that let's
say name
equals
caption
placeholder
equals
caption
and just have like three dots
now let's hit refresh and see how the
form looks
if we upload ps okay good so now right
here
basically have here where it says choose
image
and
right here also
we have the
place for the form to place for the
caption in the form so now let's have
a break
i have a button
so what we want to do in this button is
button
i want to give it a class so it would
you know have the styling so let's say
class
pause
to
700
and let's give it a name
or a type
this button should be a submit type
so since we have these
right in here
and say
upload
since we have upload
let's also give this this styling of
button
from here
that class let's see our button looks
alright so it says upload the caption
the image and good don't want to remove
this or upload
i don't need that
and actually
what we can do is we can have our form
right here
and we can close the form after
this div tag
right here i just close the form
then
indented well
and then we can come down
here we add that form
get the form somewhere
so
right here
move the form there
scroll up
or not there
so this is
in a form
that's good actually
what we just need to
do go up to where the phone begins for
this we have added the formula yes and
remove that now
through back of it down
that phone
so now that is good
so now that we have this form we can
basically continue with what we want to
do what we just want to do now is to you
know allow these to be able to upload an
image put the caption hit upload send it
to our view and then
create a new object for those data
with those data so now
where we have our form right here
right here
and say action
should go
upload
and
then method should be post
and one more thing since we are dealing
with we have files in here we have to
put
nc type
multi-part
flash from
iphone data
and this works and now we can hit save
so since we have all of this now being
sent
to this upload view
and come back in here
and in our upload view we can basically
get all those data
so now in our upload view the first
thing we want to get is
if the request the method is post
if
request
the method
equals to post
will do a specific thing
that's when we'll create
data but if it's not equals to post
that means if it is i just try to go to
slash
upload without even posting anything
let's just return the user
to the home page
so that's good now if it's a post method
let's first of all
get
the
user
the image
caption
and yeah that's all we need so for the
user
it equals to request
dot user
that username
so if we come into our module.py
let's see what we need to give in our
post we don't need to put the uuid as a
default
we need to give it a user we need to
give it the image and the caption you
don't need to give it the creator that
and no like so just the image and
caption right now
so say
image
caption
the image is equals to
quest
dot files
dot get
image upload
let's just go ahead and confirm that
right here in our form this image name
was image upload
and then for caption
press
dot post
caption
that's that and now we can just easily
create a new one we can just say
new post
and be equals to post
well we use post yeah we need to import
posts probably not imported that
we imported profiles
now that we have post imported we can
say post
dot objects
dot create
user equals to the
the
also want to give it the image
so you will
give it user image and caption
so the image
goes to image
caption
equals to caption
now we've given it all these details and
come to the next line now and say new
post let's say
so
after saving it we just want to redirect
a return
direct
on page now this should work
come back here
and let's hit refresh
okay it's not running let's wait for
this to reload
and once they should load we can test
that out basically
so
loading
now we can come into upload peaks unless
the peak from here
that should open up
oda
our money job is
i'm sure able to choose a
peak
and let's just anyone
and we'll say
nature
let's upload
so it gives us this for three forbidden
and now this is because in our form
right here
we used
a post method but we didn't add the srf2
so that must yeah
let's save this and go back
try to upload again
um
here
it's upload
good so it brings us back here it
doesn't tell us anything doesn't show us
anything yet
well we come into
the admin panel and hit refresh
be able to see a new post object created
so let's wait for that to load
do it so now we see a new post object
created for john and we can have all the
details of that post
so
let's wait for that too
and i'm also going to explain something
in this url so you can see now the id
which we includes the
name
a link to the image
option the date it was rated at and now
it has zero like
so remember when i said
this uuid now replaces the id when we
say primary key equals true so now in
the link that is the identification for
that post
so that's what i was talking about when
i say
when we set primary key equals true so
that replaces the initial id that django
provides and use that as the id
so now
we are able to upload the post and
allow
everything show like this and allow you
know it to save into our database and
allow everything show like this what we
should do now is to
return
everything and show it in the post feed
when we come in here as you can see this
is still just showing all this
static images or these dumb images that
we put there
so what we want to do now is to change
this and once we get all these images
and the person that it whatever once we
get it from our database
let's do that
so now what we want to do is to go ahead
and customize this post feed
so right here once a user logs in what
we want the user to see is a list of
posts a random post
but for now because we've not
implemented the
picture of being able to follow a user
what we're just going to do is to show
a post of a list of all the posts we
have in our database
so because
we don't have the followers i'm
following when we implement that we're
going to be able to show only the posts
of the users that the logged in user is
following so you know like when you log
into instagram or any other social media
that you see
the post of people you're following or
related or anything related to that so
that we're gonna do later in this video
but for now let's just take away these
static images and stuff and let's change
it to a list of all the posts we have in
our database
so actually this is very easy what we
just need to do is to come into our
index view
and right here in our index view
we're just gonna say
so we don't need upload again
and collapse that
and right here what we want to get is
we can say feed list
or let's just say post
equals to post dot object
dot o
now this is all we need to write
and we can just pass it in here
by
using a comma
and then
like that so now we can save this and
now that we have this saved we can come
into index
and right here in index
what we can just search for
first of all we want to come
and look for where we have these these
other ones the ones below it we want to
delete any other one we have below it we
just want to leave this one and then
we're going to loop through it
so we're going to come so we have this
right here
but since we have this right here
at
some middle underscore ml we know that
that's the one for this
so
post error post one but this is under
post one good
post too let's also collapse that
load more
let's collab that we're gonna just
remove all this basically
post three
post four
load more yeah so we want to delete all
of this
we just want to keep only one so we
deleted everything to those two now if i
save it and come back in here
what i should be seeing is just only
this first plus good so this is all we
have now
and
what we just want to do is to open that
back
let's close that back first of all so
this post want to loop through it in
jungle when we are sending a list
we come back here now
when we are sending a list from here
so we said post.object or this is
basically returning to us as a list so
this that we pass into the view is a
list if we come in here now
we can basically look through that list
and just display the data we got so we
can say
for posts
in posts
and then we're gonna
end the for loop
now that we've used the for loop we can
change this to
the post
dot now coming to our models dot py file
to depose the user
so this will change to the username of
the person that posted it and let's try
that out
so that is john
so for now is we just have this job
basically just because
you know
the
what is getting from the database as the
user of john so we also want to change
the image to the image that this john
uploaded and yeah
so
i'm going to scroll down
so we have this delete post function
which you're also going to take care of
later right here where we have image src
so i want to have post dot
image
dot url
and we hit refresh
good so you can see that is the image we
uploaded that we have here now
and i just want to change the link
because right now if i click on this
it's still going to that image
that we had earlier but now i want to
change that to this image
so let's just change that
this image so whatever image it is is
what it should go to
if i click on it it opens that image
larger
so now the next thing we want to do is
to have like a caption
so for us to have a caption we're just
going to look for where we can put that
caption
so we're going to scroll down
here we have the likes
so if we come down here i think we have
it right here where it says like spy
so in this place we're just gonna
basically have a caption
and we can
say first of all let's see once you
remove all of these
so
you need this
not need this
and
let it refresh
okay good so
we're just basically taking out all the
things we don't want
and now
let's see
let's see what we have now
you know we need that
take this away
see
okay so right under here we want to have
the caption
and
well we have the caption we have like
the person that posted it and then the
caption so let's do that right now and
what we're just going to do so having it
right under here
so where we have is
right here
we are just going to say
let's have a p tag
and in that b tag
let's have
an a tag
so this a tag is going to be the user
so say post.user
and then
we also want to have the caption
of that post
post dot caption
let's save it and hit refresh so now we
have this this is the user
and then we have the caption
so now we have this but doesn't look
well let's like give this one a strong
tag
and
let's also link it
so what i want to do now is to cut this
out
this trunk
paste that in there
so we have john now strong and this so
this and this we wanted that once a user
clicks on one of these if you take the
user to the profile page of this user
we've now yet set up the profile page
fixture but let's just give it an a tag
first of all
so this has an a tag but it should stop
here
so let's just give it a link let it go
to ash first of all and if we scroll up
where we have the post
dot user that should also be in a link
like so a
put that back in there
give it that and give it an ash
now we come back here and hit refresh
once we click on it it just basically
brings us to this ash but later when
we've taken care of the
profile
in the profile page feature then we'll
be able to link that
and also we're also going to do it that
if this post is for
logged in user then the user should be
able to delete this post but basically
now we are able to upload a picture and
just showcase it in the feed let's try
that out now if we upload a pix
we wait for that to load up the
files
and now let's upload this
and let's say
the word
it's beautiful
and then we hit upload
so now that we upload we have this right
here
so you can see now that we have the
second image right here like what is in
our
database is what is showing right here
now
but as you can see the second one is
what is down so we basically want to
have the latest posts at the top so to
do that we can come in here and say for
post in post
reversed
hit refresh now you see we have the
latest boost right here
so we've been able to take care of the
field the
photos feed
and let's move to the next step
so now we stopped at this post feed
where we can just easily get the data of
all the objects we have in the post
model in our database so as you can see
right now we just have
all the
posts we have stored in our database
well normally
we are not going to stop this post feed
just like this because that doesn't make
sense we want to be able to customize it
for each specific user that means we
want to get the post of the user that i
am following so not just all the posts
we have in the database but since as i
said in the last section since we've not
implemented that yet we're just going to
stick to this stick with this for now
and what i want to do is to be able to
like a post so this button here once the
user clicks on it we want the user to be
able to like that post and also right
here it should be updated like um this
post has three like this blues has four
likes and we should once we unclick from
that button again we should be able to
unlike the post so let's just go ahead
and do that
now we're just gonna come in here the
first thing we want to do is to have a
url where we're gonna be submitting you
know the data of which post we are
liking and who is liking that post so
we're going to come here now we're just
going to copy and paste that and we're
going to have a new
path
we're going to name it like i think post
so we're just gonna copy this
put it in there for the name
and then for the views the views can't
have an iphone it needs to have an
underscore
so now let's just copy that for the view
and right here in views
we're going to close this for now
let's create a like post
function and then we can just create it
like under upload right here
df like post
take a request
and
let's pass first of all and we also want
it to have
login required so urls we save these
also now this is good the next thing we
want to do is to come into our
index.html
so right here
let's see where we have that like button
we want to be able to link it to
submit like a mini form not really a
form but let's see where we have the
like button first of all
so
this like button right above john and
then
that should be
down here
okay
so this is the like button i suppose
no this is the
other button to download so now this is
the like button
and as you can see that like button is
already linking somewhere which has an
edge so what we want to do is to change
it to slash like post
like i've imposed so now once you use
that click on this you go to slash like
i've imposed but you want to go there
by sending some data so let's send
posts
id so want to send the post id
and the post id will be
post dot id
let's save this and check this out
i'm gonna refresh this page now
and then once i overrun this button if
you look at the bottom left corner
you're gonna see that we have slash like
posts
a question mark name post underscore id
equals to the id of that specific post
now we go to the next one we see the id
of that post so each post has a
different unique id but since now once
we click on that we're sending it to
that view it's going to give us an error
now that this
particular place does not return
anything so it doesn't have written an
http object but that's for now but what
we want to do is once we click on that
it will take us to that view but within
like a millisecond it's going to take us
to that view automatically
create a new object in our database and
that object is going to be under a model
that we're going to create and that
model is going to take you over liking
post so when a user likes a post you're
going to create an object app this post
id was liked by this user so that object
is that module is going to have two
fields
and then once it does that it's going to
check if the user has liked this post
already or he has not liked this post so
if he has like this post is going to
update that and he does not like this
post
if he has liked this post he's going to
update that here by reducing the likes
but we are not like this post what
you're going to do is to increase the
likes so now let's just go ahead and do
that and once that is done we want you
to redirect us back to this
right here in our modules file first
thing we want to do is to have a new
model
say class
like post
and that should obviously take from the
model dot
models
and what we just want to do is to have a
post
underscore id
and that should just be a models dot
character field
and let's have a max length
like
100
and the username that's the
name of the user that is liking this
post let's say
models.character field
and i should have a max length
100
and let's say df
the r
itself
i'm just gonna do is to return
self.username
so this is what we have now and what we
want to do before we have unreal
migration is to go ahead and import that
here in admins.py file so we can
register it in our admin panel
copy paste
copy this
paste and save so now that should be
registered but before we go and view
that let's make sure we come here
it gives us an error i said models.model
does not
doesn't exist should be model.model that
models dot model
i come back in now i'm cut out of that
okay so that you just got out of that
and i will say python
manage dot py make migrations
and this will save the changes and tell
us what has been updated
now we can say python
manage dot py migrate
now this is just going to migrate that
to our database good now let's run our
server back
and once we have our server running
good we can just come back to
our browser and actually the tab where i
remember i opened an incognito tab by
private window where i log the admin
user in i close that tab so just have to
open that again and quickly log in the
admin user so slash admin and remember
that earlier in this tutorial we created
unique admin user
let's just log that in
good so now we log in now we now see a
new model called like posts so now once
a user like a post issue update here i'm
also using unlike you should also update
here let's just go ahead and do that
so to this point now we've created the
model
right here we've been able to link to
where
the user will be able to save whatever
the user is doing without liking your
own liking and what we just need to do
nice to go to this view
the view of this url and now collect
this data and do the rest
so now let's import like post
and right here where we have this like
post
the first thing that we want to do
to just get the username
of the currently logged in user
to say
request.user but username
so that's that
just got the username of the currently
logged in user
and then the post id which was sent from
our template
so say request
dot
get
dot get
and what we just want to do is to get
post underscore
id
so we have that now
and then what we want to do
is to get the post object
so since we have the id of that post we
want to get the object the entire object
of that post to say post
is equal to posts
posts dot objects so this post is
actually the post model which we
imported if i scroll up here
right here you see we have that post
suppose dot objects
dot get
want to get the one in which the id is
equal to the post id that has been sent
so now that we have that
what we just want to do we want to first
of all
check
as this user liked this post before so
we want to check if this specific post
has been liked by the currently logged
in user so that we know whether we want
to like or unlike
so what we're just going to do is say
like like filter
don't want to filter the database and
say like post dot objects
dot filter
post
underscore id
equals post underscore id
so let me before i continue let me
quickly explain what i want to do so i
want to
get if there is actually an object in
our database in which the post id if i
come to my models in which the post id
is equals to the currently post the
current post that has been sent here and
the username is equals to the currently
logged in username now if we have an
object like that that means this user
has really liked this post so we know
that we need to unlock that's what i
want to do
well if you are very familiar with
jungle you know that when i want to get
just one model i mean just one object i
need to use dot gets not the filter
but that's when i want to get just one
model and that's what i want to do here
i just want to check if one model exists
but if i do that in this case it's going
to throw me an error because right here
i am basically not
if that does not exist it's going to
throw me an error now i can use an if
statement and say if like those post
dots
gets blah blah blah exists or not but
it's still going to throw me an error
and
to solve that what we just want to do is
to use filter
now when we have filter we can just say
onto fuel tank with the post style is
equal to this post id and then
the
username
is equals to this username that we got
which is the currently logged in user
so
if we have that already
what we want to do now is to say at the
end of this because as we know this is
going to give us back a list but we
don't want to get one module one object
we'll say dot first
so now this is going to give us just the
first one it gets which should even be
only one in the first place
so now that we have this what we can
just say is i'm just going to come here
and i'm going to say if
like filter
is equals to none
now this means that if it checked
through the database and you didn't see
any object that corresponds with these
inputs that i gave
then that means the user has no you like
this post so we want the user to be able
to like display us so say new like
would be equals to
like post
dot object
dot create
i want to create a new one in which the
post id
equals to post id
the username
equals to username
now we can just say new like
dot save
and now
the next thing we want to do the reason
why we got this
post object so remember that once we got
to the id of the post we have to get the
object that post now this is because if
we come back here we'll see that in this
post object we have a field called
number of likes now we just want to
increase the number of likes when a user
likes that post and decrease the number
of like when the user unlikes that post
so let's do that
right here now after saving that after
creating a new like object
what we can just do is to say post dot
number
of
likes
should be equals to
post
dot number of likes
for this time around plus one since a
new user is liking this post now we can
just also say post dot save
after saving the letters
return
redirect
the user
back to the home page so this should
work now when a user tries to like the
post it should create a new object in
the database
but after this what if
this
query that we try to search for already
exists that means the user already likes
this post then we want users to be able
to unlike this post what we would just
say is like
filter dot delete
so we just want to delete that
particular object that we got since it
is i want to unlike it and then we'll
say post the number of likes
this time around -1
and we can just say post
dot save
and we can also do the same thing by
redirecting the user we say return
redirect
the user back to the home page
so now let's save this and then let's go
ahead and test this out so first of all
if we
click refresh we see that we have no
post object here but we come here now
and hit refresh
and we try to like this
so
nothing shows it didn't return any
response but if we come back here and
hit refresh
we now see that we have a new object and
if we go in there we have the post id
and the username of the user that liked
that post
well if we click on that like button
again
and we come here and hit refresh we'll
see that that is gone and that is
because these are unliked so these are
unliked we don't want to have that
object again so one more thing let's
just try to like this other post
so now we come here
we obviously have that here now and if
we go to that post
which is i think the latest one
will now see okay so it's not this one
is the second one
that's post
you go to the second one now we see that
it has the number of likes is one well
if i come back here and
pick it again and i come here i need to
refresh now the number of likes is
but that basically just
fix
or solves that that we want to do
now the next thing we want to do is to
just show like the number of likes this
particular post have we want to show it
on there so what we should do in there
is to go into the index the py index
index.html actually i'm going to come in
here
and then
just write on the
here
so right here what we want to have
is just to say
let's just make sure we are in the right
place here right here okay so what we
want to have right now
is
have it on the inside the same div tag
so want to have like a p tag
and
let's just say
liked
by
one person let's give it like that
unless it refresh
okay so
it just is like by one person for
everything but we're gonna get the data
from the back end
so this is liked by one person okay but
even if it's not like by one person it
just says that
to change this now what we want to do to
come into our views dot py actually we
don't need to go into our views.py
because right here we're already getting
all the post objects and we are sending
it here so each of what we are looking
through already as the number of likes
because each of the post object has the
number of likes filled in there so now
we can use this field just come in here
and say liked by
post.number of likes person
so now you see this one says like by
zero person you don't say like by zero
person if i
like it now it says like by one person
but this is the same like by zero person
because nobody liked it but if i say
if i like it
one person i dislike this zero person so
that's what
we want to do to that but
this is wrong grammatically in english
so let's just change this
to be right so what we want to do is use
an if statement in the jungle templating
style
so we can say
if
post dot number of likes
is equals to zero
then what we want to do
let's copy and paste this is to say
no likes
no likes
so since reports have no likes let's
just say no likes
but
want to have
an else if statement so just say
alif
post
dot number
of
likes
if it's equals to one
i will say liked by one person
but now
if it's equals to anything except zero
and one that means
it is from two above
so now we can say else
liked by
whatever people just
make sure that is right
and now we can just simply end that if
statement
so this is just the way we write a
simple if statement in the jungle time
register so we create this statement
like this and this is where we end it
now in python we just end the statement
using the indentations python already
understand but since html the
indentation doesn't really matter here
we have to end it using the tags
so now we save that we are coming and
hit refresh this says no likes because
it doesn't have a like but this is like
by one person so this i have no likes if
i like it now it says like by one person
wonder person like it now it should say
liked by two people
so now we've taken care of that
everything is working with the likes to
this section
so now that we are done with allowing a
user to like a post and showing the
amount of likes that that post have the
next thing we want to do is to customize
the profile page so right now to this
point we don't have any profile page so
that means if we see a post and we click
on the username it doesn't take us the
profile page of that user and we can't
even see our own profile page so let's
go ahead and add that picture
now we're just going to go back to vs
code
and we're going to come into the urls.py
file so in here the first thing i want
to do is to create a new url so under
let's say
upload i can just say profile
and what i can say after this profile is
slash
and i'll say str column pk
and then i can close it
so now this is basically just gonna
have the profile page slash the user so
that's gonna be the link to get a user's
profile page and i can take it to views
dot profile right here
and the name can also be profile
so now i can come into views
and i can just close up this like post
and right here
i can say def profile
request
and i'll just return
render
request
profile
dot html
so this profile is coming from
this profile.html
so that's the template we're gonna use
so now to be able to go to user's
profile we need to go to profile slash
the username that's what we're gonna do
so first of all let's go
into our app and see what that is going
to give us so let's say profile
slash so the username goes here
but now nothing is going to happen
because we didn't even collect this so
right here after
you know specifying requests we also
need to specify the pk so the pk is what
we collected from the url right here we
said
pk is the name or is the key and the
data type is a string so we can come
back here and just save this since we
collected it
yes it refresh
press yeah our app is running
and let's see
good so this is just the demo profile
page very simple
and as you can see just have this image
we can go to the ohm and it has this
dummy like numbers now right here and
there's a button to follow
and all this so what i want to do now is
to customize this so
first of all like when we enter like
john
then we should see all the details of
john of this if you see his profile
image
user name is bio of the post and me as
the currently login user should be able
to follow him i'm also going to do that
after this section
what we want to do now is to go
into the views of this profile first of
all let's also add this login required
and now what we just want to do is to
get the user object
first of all of this user that we're
passing i'm going to say user
underscore object
it'll be equals to user
dot objects
dot get
user name
equals to pk
now that we have the user object we can
get the user profile using the object
the user underscore profile
equals to
profile
dot
objects
dot get
the one in which user
is equals to user
object
and now that we have that
we can basically pass this user profile
what we want to do first of all is to
pass the let's pass the user object
okay because we're going to pass a lot
of things like if we come in here we're
going to pass the user object user
profile i'm going to pass the amount of
posts that i use i have it's better we
do this in the context so
let's move this first of all and say
context
and the equals to no not a list
like this and we can say
user object
give it user object
and
also the user profile
give it the user profile
and let's see another thing we need to
pass so we are passing the user object
just so we can guess like the username
of the user we already have that but
let's just pass it we later we might
want to get you might need a data from
that object later but what we really
need is this pro user profile because
that's where the profile is made by your
goals but another thing you want to get
is the amount of posts that specific
user have
so to do this we are going to have to
say
user
posts
now is equal to post
dot object
dot
filter i want to filter the one in which
user is equals to pk
so if we come here to confirm in the
post model the user is just a character
field which we are giving us the
username so the one in which user is
equals to pk as we know this pk is the
username of the currently viewed user so
the one in which users go to pk that's a
post that is belonging to this user that
we're looking for so once we have that
we just query all of it and what we can
just do we can say user
post length
is equals
to let's say
len
and we can just find the length
of this outpost
now once we find the length
or once we get the length of this user
post we can be able to use that
right here so we can just say the amount
of post another thing we can do now
since we already have all the users all
the posts of this user we can just
render it here so we can also click on
it you know to view that specific image
so we're just gonna do is to come back
and once we come back here now
we're gonna pass this
and say use our post
and also
user post length
and they just have a comma and now we
can just pass context
now let's save this now that we have
this saved what we can do first of all
we can use this user profile now we're
going to come into profile.ht
and right here you can see that we have
the username of
what we're just gonna say is
user profile
dot
user
dot username and we come here and hit
refresh
what we should see in the title is
profile iphone john let's come back here
and see what's up
so okay right here we have one we didn't
let's see
okay right here should be
colon
and that should reload
good so if we come here now and hit
refresh
as you can see now we have profile
iphone john good
so now what we want to do
is to just scroll down
first of all let's copy this profile i
think john so we're just gonna
copy this tag
i'm gonna come down to
where we have
the user name
so let's see
this is where the bio is damaged
username should be up
right here where we have the user name
we are just going to say user profile
user.username
and for the bio
value goes here so right here we say
userprofile.bio
it doesn't need a user anymore any other
thing
so that's for that
and let's go ahead and check that out so
now we see
john
and here we see user provided by you
that's because
we used only one
we scroll down only one tag to close it
so that should not be now if we hit
refresh we see the value of the user i
am done i am the coolest kid
now let's scroll up back
and let's add the profile image of
john so what do we need to do that
is right here
what we need
is user profile dot profile
img
let's save that and hit refresh
that doesn't work because we need to say
dot url so whenever we're getting an
image we need a dot url to get a
specific area of that image that it
refreshed good so now we have the
profile image of john
and
this
where we have
let's see
scroll down here
we have upload profile photo we don't
need this because we already have where
so if you come here you see we have this
we don't want that because right there
where user can
upload
profile photo in the home page but this
is working so
we have the username profile picture the
bio i want to have
the amount of posts we're not going to
do for these followers i'm following for
now because we haven't implemented our
picture we're going to come back to it
once we have done that
so let's go ahead
and say and configure this post
so let's search for where we have 11
post
so right here what we're just going to
say
is
come back in here now you see we passed
user post length
so we're just going to say we're going
to change this 11
user post length post
so these are two posts
so what we can just do here also now
is to use an if statement so let's just
and say
if zappos lens dot post
is equals to zero
then we can just simply say
no post
like you just have no post
and we can copy this again
and we can say l if is that personality
equals one and we can say one post
dummies with anything more than that
then
copy these
and paste and we can say
posts now we have that so now you say
two posts with an s so we have an error
so
use our post length
so right here
says we didn't close the if tag what we
just need to do
to come
down where we have this
and just basically post close that if
tag by saying end if
now we save that and hit refresh
we have to post
the next thing we want to do now is this
profile
is this posts
as you can see we just have three lists
of posts right here but what we really
want to have is the
amount of post the user has then it
should just show the image and one user
clicks on that image should open the
image
wider
so that is what we want to have and
let's go ahead that
if we come back in here now
oh we're just gonna say
i'm gonna scroll down
all the way down to
right here so you can see we have one
two
three
gonna remove that
and what we're gonna say is
right here in this list
i'm gonna say
for
let's say for posts in
and right here
we sent user posts
all the posts and user posts let's just
go ahead and enter a for loop right here
i'm saying for post in user posts
what we want to do
is just to
show
the url of that image
that post
we're going to remove all of these
we're gonna say
post
dot
image dot url
let's save it and hit refresh
and we see the two posts and that in
those images
we click we click on it still take us to
this image so to do that
i'm just going to copy exactly the same
thing
and change it for you
so let's just cancel of that
let's hit refresh
once we click on one it takes us to
the one for that you click on the other
one takes us to the full image of that
so as you can see what we are just doing
now is that we got
everything we need all the data we need
and then we just looped through it in
here
since we have all of this done now we
are pretty much
done with
this profile image
so
yeah now let's continue with the next
part of this project
so in the template of this profile page
once we click on this image it's just
meant to like pop up a model here that's
going to allow us to like slide through
all of the images as posted
so
that is not working what is just
happening is that it's taking us to the
full image
so that means there is a problem
somewhere if we try to look for it
we'll notice that
it's probably from the static because
all those type of stuff would will for
sure be done with javascript so we
should make sure we link all the
javascript in here and we scroll here
we'll see that this is just a plain
linking without the static or the jungle
static
template so what we just need to do is
to add static
and also close it right here
so once we have that on it's safe so
let's wait for that to
refresh and now that that has reloaded
once we click on it boom what it just
does down here you see it says one out
of two so
if we scroll it takes us to the next
image if these are plus another one
takes us to the next one now that's what
is beautiful about this time
so now the fixture we want to add now is
the following and unfollowing feature
right now we just have those button if
we click on it nothing is going to
happen
what we want to do is that once we click
on this follow we want the user that is
currently logged in to be able to follow
the user that is on this page
so that is basically what we want now
but first of all let's go ahead and go
to the home
and once we go to the home let's just
log out
so i want us to create a new account
and let's create thumb
on my g dot co
let's give it a password
and sign up
so now that we have that
and save that let's just
give it this default profile image and
say
i am tom
and i screw
student
and i can say is located
let's say new york
and let's just hit save now we can go
home
and basically we just still see the post
of john you know we can like the post
likes by one person
and what we want to do now is to be able
to go to john's profile
so now we are in jump profile the reason
why i did this is because we want to be
able to
follow john from another pro another
account because we are logged in as john
and we're viewing our own profile and
later i was still going to change that
if i am logged in i am i'm viewing my
own profile i shouldn't even see this
follow button like i can't follow myself
that's impossible so i shouldn't see
that i'm also going to add that at
some time in this video but first of all
since we have this now let's go ahead
and coding so we're just going to come
back to
ps code
first we want to do is to create a model
for this followers account
so again we'll say
class
and we just say followers
count
i'll say models dot model
and this will just take two fields
first one will be follower
that's the person that is following
that dot chart field
max underscore length
so what's going to go into this
particular field is the username of the
person that is following another user
and user now is the person that is being
followed
character field
marks on the score length
was 100 so now let's
just turn
or show
person that has been followed as the
username of the person that has been
followed
the return
of that user
we can save this now and come into our
command prompt
we're just going to go ahead and opt out
of this server first of all
and we're going to run
make migrations
and then
after making migrations we just want to
migrate the database is
python money dot py migrate
that's done and let's just run our
server again
so as that is trying to run we're gonna
come in here and we want to register
these new followers account model
we want to register it in our admin
panel so we have to open admin dot py
import that
and register it
like this so that's going to register it
for us and now if we come right here
and we go to home
we should now see followers count so
this is just going to store the
data of everybody following each other
who is following who
is being followed
that's going to store it and later on
we're going to be able to use that to
guess
get the amount of people that is
following a user and the amount of
people that user is following
so now that we have these we have this
followers account
let's now create a new url now this new
url is gonna
so let me come back here once you use
that click on follow the request is
gonna be sent to that url to you know
create or update that particular
followers object
let's come back here now we're gonna
create a new url on this url
we can just make it
we can make it follow
so we can save views that follow name
dot name cos follow and we can add a new
view
and say request
and let's just pass first of all and
then this we also need to be logged in
before we can access
following picture before we can follow a
user
now let's just save that
so now that we have all of these what we
just want to do
is to come into our profile page
then we're gonna just
wrap this is already wrapped in a form
and what we're just gonna do is to have
some
fields and use this follow like as a
submit button to trigger that the
trigger that requests to be sent to this
photo url and then once we do that we're
going to come here get all those values
and then create an object
let's come into profile and as you can
see with the template already
wraps this in the form
and since this is enough form already
what we can just do is to specify the
method
and the action so we can say action
first of all that's where is this going
to
let's take you to dot follow
slash follow and the method
is post whenever using a post method
make sure to add our csrf token
so now that we have all of these what we
just want to do is to come in here
right here
where we have this button
let's just
make that a part what we want to do now
first of all we want to have
an input field
but the type of this field wants it to
be hidden
and want to give it like a value
of user dot user name
so what we're getting is a currently
logged in user actually we can also do
this on the you know on the back end on
the views like
when we trigger that button once we come
here we can just get it currently logged
in user you can do it anyhow you like
this is just showing you know multiple
ways you can do it or anyhow you feel is
more secure
or that you prefer to run your
application or counsel do it like this
might not be as secure as donated
backing but this is also another method
what we can just do now is to say name
is equals to follower so this is the
person that is following another user
that's a currently logged in user that's
the authenticated user i want to have
another field also
so the other field is also going to be
hidden and this one is going to be user
object dot username so this user object
is
this the user of this person who are
viewing the profile we're viewing or
just getting a username
and then
this one should be user so since we have
those two inputs now
right here this button we're going to
make it
submit button so we can just say type
equals
button
so since this is already been made
submit button
we are basically good to go
because this is ready
a submit button that means
what when we click this button it sends
these two values
to slash follow now you can go to slash
follow and go collect all of these
values
so right here in follow
first thing we're going to do is to say
if request
the
method equals to
post
first of all let's pass
then we can say else
return
redirect
let's say
to the home page so if is a post method
we're going to do what we want to do why
is there a post method and someone just
trying to access slash follow without
doing anything just redirect the person
to the home page
so now that we have that what we want to
do now is to get the follower
as the person being full not the person
that is following someone else
we can say request
dot post
follower
now let's also say for the user
and that's request the exposed user so
since we have these details now
let's first of all import
that follower account
model
now that we have this model
we can come in here and what we want to
do we first of all want to check
if this person is already following
if the currently logging user is already
following this user so the only way we
can check is we're going to query the
database and say
does
is there an object in which the follower
is the currently logged in user and the
user is the person that is being viewed
so if there's an object like that that
means that this user is already
following that user and is trying to
unfollow that user or if there's not an
object like that that means the user
wants to follow this
to say if
follower count
dot objects
dot filter
now i don't want to get one object but i
explained earlier in this tutorial why
we are using dot filter
but filter the one in which follower
is equals to follower
and then user
is equals to user
then
dot first very important
so if this exists
we want to delete that so say delete
follower
now because of follower account
dot object
dot get this time around since you
already know that exists
equals follower
and
user
is equals to user
so we're just getting the specific
object in which this is true
and once we have that
i'm just going to say
delete your follower
dot delete
and now we can just return
redirect
back to the profile page of that
specific user
but this is only if the person already
follows and is trying to unfollow but
what if the person doesn't follow yet
and is trying to really follow this user
say else
new follower
equals to
follow account.object.create
the one in which follower is equals to
follower
and user
equals to user
now say new follower.save
and we're just also gonna redirect back
to
the page of that user
now
let's see
all this is working now it should be
working now let's go ahead and test it
we're gonna come
in here
let's first come to our
modules and make sure that
i confirm that there is no object here
we hit the refresh button now
and we say
follow
as you can see it brings us back to this
page we don't get anything we don't even
know that we followed we're gonna do
that later and show the user that you
really follow this user but we come back
here and hit refresh
you see a new object being created so as
we can see a new object wasn't created
from here let's see why
okay it doesn't even give us an error
here
let's try to opt out of the server
and run that again
and everything
seems to be working here so that should
definitely work
let's try to do that again
let's first of all refresh this page i
think that was the error we did we
didn't refresh the page but anyways
let's say follow so now it brings us
back to this page come back here and hit
refresh
as we hit refresh it still
doesn't update that so it doesn't create
a new user or anything like that
so now let's go back to our code and go
see what's wrong
so if we come back here
we are saying
if
the request that object
filter
is there and we just want to delete that
follower i'm doing that by followers
count.objects.get
follower follower yeah and then we're
deleting the user right here and after
that we're redirecting the user to the
after doing that
blower equals
account
create yeah
and then we are saving this one this
time around
and then after doing that we are
redirecting the apache
page
so this should totally work let's just
make sure our
url's
specified correctly
if we come here let's see
from also works
so the action is going to slash follow
that works
and
another thing we should check using the
csi of token
we have this inputs
so everything should be working fine
let's just go ahead and try that again
now let's hit refresh
and just
so if we hover over this
we're gonna see if you look at the left
bottom corner
bottom left you're gonna see that it's
as
is linking to slash profile slash john
we shouldn't be so there's like an a tag
that is linking to that
let's check that out if that's okay so
we see that this is in an a tag and it's
basically linking to
this page so let's first of all clear
that out we don't want that to link to
anything we want it to submit
but since we have that cleared out we
can come here and refresh
now we don't see that link at the bottom
left corner now let's get this follow
let's refresh the page
okay ready for that to load
and we hit follow
so as we do this nothing happens so
first of all let's see nothing happens
so that means there's something
wrong right here in our
code
and what is wrong we just need to check
so
we have an a tag
we need this title just clearing our
code
and then in there we have this button
this button we need type submit as a
style
and does the border also
take so everything seems to be working
and this button should
let's see
let's hit refresh again and let's try
to click on the button
so i think
we just need to change this tag let's
see if it's a p tag
so that takes that away from there but
let's click on this button now and see
that still doesn't work
we're just going to try to do
to see if this is linear to any class
let's take that back to an a tag
data repo
let's see
let's hit refresh button
and it follow
so now that we don't have the data repo
it just isn't working but what we can do
now is just to take this out
okay
so i'm sure some of you may have noticed
the error
while i've been searching for it
so there's nothing wrong with this data
reported class basically what is wrong
is the type is meant to be submit and
not button
let's just try that out again
allowing this to load and
yeah so now it brings us back to this
page that means something must have
worked let's go back in here and hit
refresh
good so now we can see that we have a
new
object polarized term under
that is what we want to see
now that we
have this
the next thing we want to do
is to show the amount of users that this
specific user has
the amount of users this user
have
now to do that
are going to have to
come into the views of profile
so we've taken care of a user following
and unfollowing let's just test that one
more time if we click on this follow
button now
and then we come in here and hit refresh
that's gone
now i said we want to get the amount of
followers i'm following but before we
even do that there's one thing that is
important that we do
what we want to do is that once the user
has followed the user we want we don't
want to show follow a game now we want
to show unfollow so the user can know
that
okay this user is a user i'm following
already so i want to follow this user
now
and another thing i want to do is that
if
this user is viewing his own profile we
don't want him to even see the follow
button what we want him to see is like a
button that goes to his account settings
for example so the user can go to
now
let's do that first of all let's make
sure that if this user
is himself
he should not be seeing the
the follow button
so we're gonna come back in here
what we're gonna do
i'm gonna say come back right
yeah so no not here index
as profile
if
the user object.username
so if the user object the username it's
just equals to
user dot username i'm zip is equal to
the currently logged in user
we don't want to show this
so
else
we want to show this then let's end the
if
so we've entered the if tag
and now
what we want to do
just to say
instead of this button it's gonna be a
button also what i'm gonna do is to
copy this
paste it here
and it's not going to have a type
button
and this data is going to have weights
linking to and that should be slash
settings
save that now if a communion is
refreshed
only seeing this follow button because
we are viewing the profile page of
another user but we logged in as tom
and i review tom
actually this
should be
account settings okay now the reason why
that is not account settings because we
didn't change that here
let's say account
settings
and we hit refresh
what we see now is account settings and
if we click on that
it should take us to the page where we
can
let's see
if we overall what
it just brings us back to this page
let's make sure that it's working well
if we look at the bottom left corner we
see that it's supposed to link to
account settings
so
yeah if we come back here now
what we can just do
is to basically make sure
all right
so we don't need
this
gonna come
here
not for you it's for the account
settings
you don't need a button
you just need the a tag
now that we have this we can hit refresh
and once we click on account settings it
take us
to the settings page for this user now
we can go back to wherever we were and
we can view the profile page of
john
good so this is what we want to see so
the next thing we want to see
is to be able to
change this to like
unfollow when we are following the user
so let's come back here first of all
because this has been altered
so let's save this and see if that
affects
this button
that doesn't
go back
gonna
redo
okay so let's see
let's just save that first of all come
back here and hit refresh
this is the button for this
and then if we remove the button for
account settings let's see
refresh
so that doesn't alter it when we go to
tom
that's our terms on looks
and if we come back here good so we have
that settled and what we want to do as i
said is to change this from follow when
we are following that specific user
for us to do this we need to come into
view
so now
in this view we don't need follow view
again what we need is this profile view
and one thing we want to get
is
follower
equals to
request
dot user dot username that is the person
that is following
and user
is equals to
bk
so now that we have these two what we
can just say is
if
follower
account
dot objects
dot filter
follower
equals to follower
and user
goes to user
but first
so if this
is actually in our database
then that means the user is already
following this user that is viewing so
let's say button
text we're just having a new variable
and then we want it to be on follow
else
one button text
equals to follow
so now we want to pass button text
part of the context
so what we just did there was we checked
if
there's an object which are those fields
and if there is damage the user already
following that user so we want to
unfollow
if not
should follow
so now that we have this we can save it
coming to profile
what we want to do now
is right here where we have follow we
want to remove that now and put
butting text so this button text now is
dynamic is it ah
it
changes the text
to whatever is basically in our database
adjust
if we come back here and hit refresh
and we hit follow now
see now it changes to unfollow because
we're following this user the refreshes
page are still there
so
let's refresh
and follow so now we can follow
so that is basically working now
and the next thing we want to do is to
have
followers count right here
so another thing to do now is just to
come into
views
right here
i'm gonna say user
follow us
will be equals to
follow us
counts.object
dot filter
one in which user is equals to pk
what we're doing is that we are getting
his full last count model and we're
filtering only the one in which the user
now this user is the person that has
been followed so i think the one in
which the user is gross to pk and pk is
the username of this user that we are
viewing so all the times that this user
is being followed is what we want to get
and what we just want to do is to
calculate the length of that
so now that is an integer which
calculates the length
and we want to do exactly the same thing
for the following
um
back
come back to views
you want to do exactly the same thing
and change this to user
following
and now
blue scans dot object or filter the one
in which the follower
equals to pk
now we have all of these let's also pass
it in this context
and the user following
so now we have all of this in this
context dictionary we now come into
this place into the profile.html page
where we have all these followers and
following what we can just do now these
followers we can change it to
user followers
and this following
you can change it to user following
now let's go back and hit refresh and
see what's up
so it says zero follower zero following
but if i follow this user now
what so it gives us an error of unbound
error at profile john blah blah blah
it doesn't work
what we just want to do
i'm in here but we need to make sure
that everything's coming from so it's
coming from user followers
right here so it says assigned before
use
what we can just do
back to views
okay so it's because all of these we put
it inside the else
indentation so inside the else block
that's why if we have anything the else
block we're supposed to have it in the
if block but we don't even want it in
there so
we just want it on its own but now that
should work and let's just hit refresh
now it has one follower i unfollow
followers back
yeah so that is working another thing we
want to change is this follower so it is
zero follower it shouldn't have an s so
let's just quickly
fix that the way we've been doing it
with the other ones
so what we just want to do
is to come up here
in the profile
and we're gonna go to where we have this
followers
i just disagree from
these are following
so now we're going to say
if follow us
if user followers
is equal to zero
or
user followers
is equals
to one
and if is equal to zero one we just say
follower so zero follower or one
follower
else
let's copy paste this
and right here we will say
else
want to add an s
and then we just
end the if tag
now we have this we come here and hit
refresh now we see one follower we
unfollow
this is zero follower so this is working
now let me follow this user
so that means
this user has one follower so that means
i am following one person if i come to
my accounts now i see that my following
is one i am following one person
so that is
basically what we
have achieved this profile
per section so
so far we've been able to get the
profile image basically get all the
details of the user and we'll be able to
implement the following following
we made this the text in your dynamics
so user is following already that should
be unfollow but if the user is not
following that should be
now let's move to the next section
so at this point now we are able to see
a profile
a user's profile we're able to follow
that user you know we'll see the amount
of followers the user have amount of
posts we're able to see all the posts
and all this good stuff
but in the beginning of this tutorial
when we come to home
we are just able to see the list of all
the posts we have in on this platform
that's all the posts we have in our
database that's what is shown we're not
customizing this feed for a user and
that is bad because we want a user to be
able to see
the posts of the people is following not
just anybody's post so right now it's
just showing all the opals we have on
the platform which doesn't really make
sense
what we want to do now is to be able to
customize this
to
be able to show only the posts that the
user is
the post of the people that the user is
following basically so that's what we
want to do
right now
so let's
click on this so the first thing we want
to do let's make sure that once we click
on this
and right here it takes us to the
profile page of the user
so we're going to come into index
and we'll say
user
post.user
right here it should take us to slash
profile
slash
close the user so we can just copy that
we can just search for
the other post.user
we write here
i will
refresh this
to be able to go to the
that's good and we are following this
user so now let's just go back to the
home page
and right now i'm going to come into the
views of this index and we actually need
to do a little bit of tweaking in here
what we're going to do first of all
let's assign like two
empty lists first of all we'll see
these are following
list
so this is the list
this will contain all the users that
the logged in user is following
and let's just say feed
so this feed is also a list where to
contain like the list we're gonna con
we're gonna first
query the database to get
only the
post of the persons that the user is
following and then that's gonna give us
in like a query set but we're not going
to have to convert that into a list so
the first thing we want to do is to say
user following
equals to
account
dot object
dot filter by just getting all the users
the objects of
all the users that the user is following
the one in which the follower
equals to request
dot user
dot username
so that's the user following and with
the follow passive for users
in user following
what we just want to do
is to say
user
following list want to append
the user name of each of everybody the
user is following so we say user
following does append
users
does user
and that is good so now we want to
append to the feed list so say user
names
in the user following list that we have
now
the feed lists
should be equals to
post.object
dot filter
the one in which the user is equals to
the names
and let's just say feed dot append and i
want to append
this feed
this feed list
now that we have that this is like a
query set now i want to convert that to
a list so we can look through it in the
template
what we're going to do now is to say
feed
list it's without an s now because this
is a new variable on its own
it'll be equals to
now we're going to use
a function that we need to import so
we're going to say
from
there tools
or
chain
so chain is going to be able to convert
it to a list for us
now we can just use this you know when
we have
speed
because what we want to do right now is
now convert this fee to a list
you know we can do something like list
then in there we have feed but we can't
just do that here so what we want to do
is to say
lists
chain
and in there we have
an aesthetic mark and we say feed
so now that we have this we can just
pass it
into the html
right here instead of sending posts now
or we can just send
bid list
now if i come here and hit refresh
we make sure
our server is running
so that
that's done
and let me come here and hit refresh
and let's see what we see
we still see this and the reason why we
see this is because this user is
following john
so what we're going to do now first of
all a storm
let me choose a file
i want to upload an image as tom
and what i'm just gonna do
is put an image put in a caption i'm
gonna log out and log in as john and i'm
gonna follow tom
then what you're gonna see is that i
don't see the images of
john
which is myself image i see now is of
tom
so
as i upload this now you're going to see
that it doesn't show yet it doesn't
appear yet because i don't want to see
my image i can just easily go to my
profile but i'm going to log out now and
login as john
now that i login as john
and i it's login you see i can't see
anybody profile image right here it's
just blank because i'm not following
anybody but now if i go to slash profile
slash tom
you can see tom has one post if i follow
tom now
i go to um you now see that i'm able to
see the posts of tom
so this is a very good picture let's
just log out and log in back as tom
so now john i go in there
i unfollow
come back home
i can't see any post because i'm not
following anybody once i follow john
i go back home i see john's post this is
what i want
right now want to have a unique picture
which is going to be
a downloading feature this means that a
user is going to be able to download
the image you see is on someone's post
like this is image and he loves it this
button here once you click on it you
should be able to download that image so
right now the button doesn't do anything
but let's go ahead and add that feature
come back to vs code right now
and we go to index so this is actually
very simple and fast
what we're just going to do is to look
for where we have that button
so we have it
wrote down
no is inside the for loop so
that's how we know
and this is the caption
we have
as a caption
caption is down below so it should be
before it so
right
what we're just gonna do now is touch
and search for where we have svg image
it's
this is for the like
and right here is for the download what
we just want to do is to have this
go to
this post
dot image
dot
url well we don't just want it to go
there because right now if i save this
and hit refresh if i try to click on
this what it's just gonna do it's gonna
take me to that url i want you to
download that url for me without even
going away from this page very easy with
html we can just add download right here
and we leave it blank so that is just
going to do that first
come here and hit refresh
now if we click on this
you're gonna see that it's gonna
download that image from
so as you can see at the top right
corner right here
something is about to start downloading
so as you can see
that has been downloaded i can open that
file here just gonna open that in a new
tab and that is downloaded so that's
just the feature i wanted to add thought
it was cool and let's move on with the
project
now we want to add to our website is the
search functionality let's just go ahead
and refresh this page so now if we
want to be able to search for something
and it's enter press the search button
and then
it should bring
uh
results corresponding to whatever the
user searched
so let's go ahead and do that first of
all as we can see once the user input
something we don't even have a button
where the user can click search let's
fix that first of all in the ui
we're gonna come in here now
and before we do that i just want to say
that i brought in the search.html
from
the my template so
if you have been watching from the
beginning you know that there was no
search.html yet i just brought it from
my template but you don't need to worry
about that all these files are going to
be in the github link so
don't worry about that
now what we need to do is to come into
index.html
and right here actually where we have a
diana we want to have a form
and then we're just gonna close the form
so we should be able to
have a form here
before left side yeah i close the form
somewhere around
scroll down
here right here
now that we have that done next thing we
want to do is to come into the field so
if we scroll
right here see that we have this type of
text we want to give it a name
username
and since we're giving it a name now
next thing we just want to do is to
first of all
remove
this particular search that is beside it
we don't want to search there or want to
have this dash after it so this should
be like in a box and like a search
button after it let's go ahead and do
that
right here we do not need this we don't
need any of this
and what we can just do
is to say
button
type
goes
submit
and we can close that button
and now we want to use an icon here so
first of all let's
comment out this d we don't want this to
be in this div tag just so it won't
affect this i want you to be like
outside that box of this editor because
it was in that div tag the changes i'm
making is not going to work i'm also
going to show you that
so now what we just want to do is to
come into that search.html that i
imported
and right here we want to copy this
so what this is is it's basically just
the same thing once i run the search at
html you see that it's very the header
right here is very similar to the other
of the index.html but indeed the
search.html already has like its own
form tweaked
so
that's why we can come in here and just
copy what we need
and paste it right here one more thing
we need since we're using that icon we
need to import it
so i'm just gonna link css
just scroll up
and right here
paste
so now that that is done
if we come here and hit refresh
we should see that we can search for
something i'm kind of here to sub
if i come in here now
and as i said if i don't remove this
from this
give tag
and i hit refresh
now you see it's just not looking well
that's why
i remove that from the deep line
having that said let's also leave a
space right here
let's have and
nbsp
hold on
copy that paste let's have two of it
once we hit refresh now we have a good
space beside it so that is good now we
just have this name of username and this
submit what we want to do in this form
we want it to go to
the action url no the search url
want the action to go to the search
flash search run this action to go to
slash search
and with a method of post
and once we're using the post method we
need to add a csrf token
so now we know that there is no url
named search so we need to go ahead and
create that
so let's just copy paste
and say search
i'm gonna come in here
and create a new
view
search
turn
render
request
search
dot html
we can save that let's also give it
this login required
save that also
now let's make sure that our app will
successfully once it reloads
successfully test it out
i'm back in here now
hit refresh if i search for j.o
my search it takes me to this
slide search page and i just want to
search that html as you can see it's not
really showing a result now just
showing this dummy data this static data
that we put in the search.html
but now what i want to do is that it
will show a result that is correlating
to whatever the user search
now first to do this we're going to have
to come into this view.py we're going to
have to get
the
username that the user sends it by
whatever user input we need to get it
here to save request
a method
equals to post
there is a post method say request
that's post
username
that should be
username so we basically just got the
username
and then what we want to do next is to
filter the data
so when we filter the data to only
any username that contains what the user
says just send it back
that page
what we want to do now
okay
we're gonna get
a
user object so this is just because
right here
we can see it is welcome tom which is
good but right here it doesn't show the
profile so if we go back
to the home page it shows the profile of
the user we also wanted to show the
profile we are just gonna
say
user object
equals to
user
dot objects
dot get
the one in which the user name
is equals to request
that's user
that's username
and this doesn't really correlate with
the search form but we just want to take
care of that now
and since we have that user object what
we just want to get is the user profile
it goes to profile
dot object
dot get
one in which the user
equals to user
object
and if i pass this
to the html
so
right here
valley what i want to pass is
use our profile not use object
i come back here now and
refresh
now you see that i chose to update that
so that is taken care of now back to
searching so if we the method is equal
to post get the username and then we get
the
jose user
name
object
and that will be user
dot objects
the filter
one name with the username
i'm just going to i contains
equals username
what this is doing is that by getting a
list of all the objects
in which
whatever the user search is contained in
the username so if the user search for
if there is a if they are if the user
search for tom then what it's going to
do is that it's going to go into our
database look for any user in which tom
is in the username and it's going to
return that
into this variable
now that we have that
let's first specify to
empty list so say user name on scope
profile
we have the object let's get the profile
the username underscore profile
underscore list now remember that
we have to convert it to a list let's
just
have that also as a blank
list
now save for users
in username object
user
name profile
it will stay
here right here designing profile append
what we want to append is
so what we're doing is
for users in username objects we'll say
username profile what's append each of
this user
does
that id so i want to get this one using
the idd seminar
so now i want to say append users.id now
that we have their id we say for
ids in
name
profile that's each of the id that we
get we now say profile list
it because of profile
dot object
dot filter
the one in which the id user
equals to ids so the one in which the id
user if we come into our models
we go to
profile see how we have a few name id
user which is the
id of the specific user which
which has been
talked about or used right here
right here we have id
user equal to ids now say user
name
underscore profile
underscore list
append
now we just want to append profile
lists
to it
and now that we have that
we can just say
username
profile
list
so now we just want to update that with
itself but this time i'll convert it so
we'll say list
chain
then
aesthetic
a steric of the username profile disk
you should be profile
the stereotype of the username profile
is
like this
but now that we have this what we can
just do is take it
into
like this we are taking it into
search.html
we are taking it as username profile
list so if we have that we can just
simply come here into search.html now
we're gonna scroll down i'm gonna loop
through that database what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna scroll down
and when we scroll down
actually
it's in a section
right here
so we're gonna say four
let's say user
does in username profile list
let's end the for loop immediately after
that session is closed
so end for
now that we end our for loop we can now
use this to customize it so what we want
to do now is to get the profile image so
we'll say
users
that's profile
img.url
and then
once you get the username
the users
get the username dot
name
they've come into profile
there was actually
if we come into these models
we have to say user dot user
on it what we can just do right now is
to say users.user
and after that we're going to do the
same thing for location
the users
the location
and we do exactly the same thing for the
bio
good now what we want to do is that once
a user clicks on any of these you take
the user to the profile page of that
user
so now we say slash profile
flash
user
does user
and let's also do the same thing right
here
good
so now we have this done let's now come
back here
let's go to the home page
right here now let's search for j o h
once we search for that
so it says i contain
a chaff with adrenal permitted so
if we come in here
it should be i contains with an s
just close that now
let's try that again
now let's say j o h
boom so as you can see now it says john
toronto i am john so he just shows us
the value the profile image
good and we can go to the profile of
that person
now let's search for like
term
now you can see we have some it gives us
the profile image the location and the
bio
and go to the profile of that user so
this is basically what we have
and this is how to you know build a very
simple search
picture so we can search for john and
now it just shows us that we have one
user named john
this is what we want to do
now
last picture we want to add
is the suggestions feature
so
this
right here has been with us as the
beginning of this project
and what i want to do here is just to
say users you can follow and it's going
to recommend users that
you are not already following and
users that is not you so it's just a
very simple algorithm we're going to use
anybody that are not following it can
recommend it and as long as that person
is not you which is a login user it can
also recommend it and if you do that at
random so just randomly going to pick
different people for you to recommend
let's just go ahead and do that
so we're going to come into vs code now
and what we want to do is to open up
this index
so we don't even need this post again
right here
let's just come here let me give it like
a comment and say
user
suggestion
stats
now first of all
i want to get all the users in this
platform on this platform
i'll say user.object
dot all
and
i'll have
the following
all
so this is just an empty list
but what this is going to be
is
all the people that the user is already
following that's what i want to do so
i'll say for
user
in
user following
remember that we already have this year
right here so i'll say for user in user
following
user
underscore
list
equals to
user
dot object
dot get
the one in which user name equals to
this user
dot user
now we can ask the user
following
let's go following
underscore all dot append
user list
so now that we have this what we can
just do now is to say
new suggestion list what we want to
suggest now is the people that
this user is not already following the
new suggestions
on the skull list
equals two
now this is gonna be in at least but in
here we're to have like a for loop so
it's like a specific style you see x4
x
in
list
all users
we're just converting this all users
query set into a list
so
and then we'll say
if
x not
in list
so you might already understand where
we're going with this
following so this is just the user
following all
just open and close this
so you might already guess where we what
this is so this is the suggestion list
so it's looping through the list of all
the users and saying
if
this list
is not in this list and that is the new
list so it's just getting all the lists
of the users we are following
and removing it from audio users on the
platform
so now that we have that
the next thing we want to do is to
remove
the current user from this list because
what we have now
in this new suggestion list is audio
users on the platform that we are not
following and as you know we can follow
ourselves that means we're also part of
the suggestion list and we can suggest
ourselves to ourselves can suggest a
user to himself
so what we just need to do
is to make sure that we remove
the current user from that list
so we say current
underscore user
will be equals to user
dot object
dot filter
username
was request
dot user but
username
and now let's have like
a list but like for the final suggestion
so let me see let's name it final
underscore suggestions
underscore list
now should be equal to x
for
x
in list but now
in
new suggestions list
that is not
current user and we just say
if
x naught
in list
and what we just say is current user
current underscore user so we're just
saying that he this current user must
not be
in that list so he's basically
eliminating current user from that list
and then what we can just do
to make sure that all of these
in
square brackets
that is a list
so unscrew brackets as close right there
but now that we have this
what we can just do
since we have this final suggestion is
now this is just a list of everybody
that we are not following
and
that is not us
so now we just have that unique list
but now if we pass it to the front end
or to the template and we say we just
get like let's see
yeah want to get like five
so if we just get like the first five or
something that means that's the same
thing that's just gonna show only those
people are gonna be suggested but what
we want to do is to shuffle that list
that we already have and make it random
so like once we even refresh this page a
new random random list of suggestions
comes up
so to do that first of all i have to
import random from here
to say import random
and then right here now
after this what we can just say
is to say random
dot shuffle
is final suggestion only so i want to
shuffle this final suggestion list and
what's in shuffle
what we want to get is
the final like just five from that list
right from that short foot list
but since
before we
get that we don't want to get that now
we can what we can actually do since we
already have this list we can you know
pass that list into the html but before
we pass that list
what we want to get is the profile
object of each of this list because
right now
from here
what we have is the user object so we
need to get the profile object so we can
return the profile picture the username
and maybe the location of the bio or
something so that's the main thing we
need to get this is just a step from
getting that
so let's go ahead and say
user
name on the scope profile
equals to
empty then username let's go profile
let's go list
be empty also
and we just do
similar technique to what we did in the
search so the users in final
questions list
each of the user
they will say username profile
but append users.id
dot id
now that we have that
i cannot say for
ids in
username underscore profile
we'll say profile
on the sql list
equals to profile
dot object
dot filter
id underscore user
equals to ids
now that we have that we can see user
name
underscore profile dot underscore list
underscore list
let's append
profile underscore
so now we have this what we can just say
is
let's have a new
list and say suggestions
underscore user name
underscore profile
underscore list
so the suggestions the username profile
list
goes to list
okay
we have to use the aesthetic
line here
the username profile list
that is what we need to do now that we
have these
we can just pass that
into
if i come here now
copy this this this is the final list is
being shuffled and everything
but i can just do now is to say
questions designing profile list that's
a weird name but
and
give it that but we get only
ps4
because does have to just get the first
four
and then we save it
now that we've saved it
we can come into the index
and right here in the index
what we just want to do
is to throw
so once let's search actually
let's search for
let's move to
let's just move down instead of
searching so as all the way down because
what we're looking for is these users
you can follow but this is it right here
we do not need this
and then good so i think this is it
so
what we need now
just to loop through this basic
so we have
refresh
and right here
you can see
for
suggestion
just changes our name proof
what we want to do with each of these
suggestions
first of all let's
okay so what i'm supposed to do first of
all is just to
have one of it
but let's end the full loop here
so
we just need one let's
remove this remaining three
right here
just remove this
do the same here
and we do exactly the same thing here
now that is good if i
hit save
and press refresh i'm just gonna see
this four times so it says list is not
callable so let's come back here
and
what we just need to do is right here
this doesn't need the two
value braces just need
one for this i want to close this
now we save it
and then we go back here and hit refresh
let's make sure our site is running
so now you see
that it works but nothing is showing
here and this is because remember we got
all the users on our platform
and we said
basically it should render
the ones i'm not following and the ones
that are not me
so
um the ones that is me
and the ones that i'm not following is
basically everybody on the platform so
that's why it doesn't have anything yet
but let's see let's see
let's come back here
come into index
so for suggestion in suggestion
what i can just do
is to say
suggestion
action
that's user
i'm gonna save it
and then right here i'm gonna hit
refresh
so still the same thing what i'm gonna
do is to come here
and then unfollow john
now that i am not following john
if i go back home
it's refreshed on this oh boom now you
can see now that it recommends john for
me since just because i'm not following
john again so this is actually what i
want so if i follow john it won't
recommend john for me again
what i just want to do is to go back to
follow john
slash profile
slash john
let me follow john
once i come here doesn't recommend
anybody because i'm following everybody
on the platform
but now let me log out and what i want
to do is to create a bunch of accounts
so i can say
you can just say i don't know tammy
e
at g dot co
your password
sign up
so
is doug jane
i am tommy
from the uk
and right here we can just say london
now we can save that
and once we come home we have an account
for tommy and you can see that tommy has
been recommended john and tom because
she isn't following any of those users
i'm also going to change this to
the profile image of the user and these
followers are just going to put like the
bio or something
so
but now let's just log out again and
create like two more accounts
so let's just say
emry
hrg.co
and
deserve
password
and let's wait for that to create
to remove that let's say
a
i am henry
and you should know that
listen new
jersey
and we can save that
and go to the home page and now it's
been recommended tom tammy and john
so let's just go back
log out
create a new account
now let's just create jasper
a rg dot co
let's give it a password submit
and now
you just see
just per year
and let's say
i'm from
l.a
now let's just save that and go to home
so it's been recommended and rejoined
tommy and tom
so
one thing is if i refresh this you see
it's random now time is on top if we
have a bunch of people like android
people is just going to be picking them
randomly so now let me log out and log
in back as tom
now you see that i've been recommending
three people been recommended just part
time me and henry now let me go back and
finish that up so right here in
suggestion.user
let's change this to suggestion.
bio
and
also where we have this follow want it
to be view user so to take them to the
you the profile page of the user
and then once it takes them there they
can follow the user right there
right here now we can just say slash
profile
slash
suggestion.user
and one more thing is the image
so we can just say
suggestion that's profile
img.url
and
i am going to slash profile
slash suggestion.user so now let's save
this
from here and hit refresh
okay and as you can see we have this
angry i am henry and you should know
that we have jasper jasper here we have
tommy tommy i'm from the uk
so we have all this good we can go ahead
and view henry he doesn't have no
follower no post
he doesn't have anything but we can
support him and follow him
and now that we're following him if we
come to home we don't see henry there
again we are only being recommended
these two people but now if every
creates a new post we're gonna see every
post right here
now we've been successfully able to add
these
suggestions
right here so this very simple and basic
algorithm we built right here
i hope you understood everything we did
to this point
we are pretty much done with this
project
so let's just go
like got the project like give it a
final review but just recap on
everything we've done
so
right now you can see it suggests me to
follow a username jasper but it is
feature where he just suggests us random
users
if i follow jasper now
now he has one follower but they also
added his followers and following style
and now if i go home it doesn't suggest
me jasper again
and it also
shows me
the post of the users i'm following so
if jasper that i just followed if he
uploads a post i'm going to see it in my
feed so we customize the feed but only
the users are following and we can like
post
like it
you liked it like by one person now if
you like it no likes
and we can also click on this
on and then it's going to take us to the
profile page of john
and we can follow on follow him
and show us the bio his username is
profile pics and if we click on
images he posted we can just slide
through
all the images
back to the own
and we can also use this search
functionality like we know we have john
so let's say we are looking for john i
will just search joh
it's search
now you see that it brings us john
gives us the location and this bio so if
we click on that
we're gonna see
profile
and we also added
this way user can upload a pics
and choose the file and the caption
right here we also have this account
settings they can change this profile
picture changes by your update is look
so this is a basic word true of
everything that we did in this video in
this course
so there's still a lot that can be done
to this project so but i hope with
everything you've learned and the
knowledge you've learned from this you
can customize it and also add your own
pictures you know if you want to do the
comments or you want to do
anything you want to do i hope it's what
you've learned you can be able to
thank you for watching or taking this
course and finishing you up to this
point
thank you so much